Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Februar, der letzte Donnerstag im zweiten Monat dieses Jahres. Und das bedeutet natürlich vor allem wieder eins, das Studio von Fritz sieht gerade aus, dass jeder Techniker, der hier reingucken würde, die Hände entsetzt über dem Kopf zusammenschlagen würde, was daran liegt, dass hier viel zu viele Leute drin sind, insgesamt drei andere außer mir. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Und die haben auch noch jede Menge Technik mitgebracht und Computer. Und das steht hier alles auf den Pulten und das ist ganz fürchterlich. Und das bedeutet eins, es ist Chaos Radio. Und dazu herzlich willkommen. Zu Gast sind heute in Reihenfolge von links nach rechts Wetterfrosch.
Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Elektra Wagenrad.
Hallo.
Und Herr Urban.
Hallo. Das heißt Urbach.
Urbach, um Gottes willen. Ja, okay, die erste Runde geht schon auf mich. Guten Abend. Es geht heute um Internet in Krisengebieten. Und wir meinen damit ausnahmsweise mal nicht die Glasfaserwüste im Friedrichsein, sondern diesmal die echten Krisengebiete. Also ihr habt es vielleicht gehört, in Ägypten ging es hoch her. In Libyen geht es jetzt gerade hoch her. Und in all diesen Staaten wird das Internet abgeschaltet, eingeengt, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch andere Gegenden. Da gibt es erst gar kein Internet und da möchte man es irgendwie hinbringen. Und wie man das macht, das sprechen wir heute hier. Ihr seid natürlich auch herzlich eingeladen, beide Sendungen mitzumachen, indem ihr einfach anruft. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Falls ihr während der Sendung Fragen habt oder etwas genauer wissen wollt oder etwas vorschlagen wollt, wie man vielleicht noch Internet irgendwo hinkriegen könnte, wo es noch nicht ist, dann wählt diese Telefonnummer. So, wer von euch drei ist jetzt übrigens alles beim CCC? Das ist ja das Chaosradio, also das Radio des Chaos Computer Clubs und sind aber meistens nicht alle Gäste Mitglieder. Also wer ist jetzt dabei? Ihr dürft ruhig reden. Also wenn ihr das anzeigt, können die Leute das vor dem Radio nicht sehen.
Die Elektra?
Ich zieh das durch. Ich zieh das eiskalt durch.
Der hat heute vergessen, seinen Mitgliedsantrag abzugeben.
Verpeilungsnote schon mal sehr gut, passt also gut in den Club, würde ich sagen. Herzlich willkommen. Warum seid ihr heute hier? Also erklärt doch mal kurz, was ihr so macht.
Ich dachte mir, also diese Sendung sollte vielleicht auch mal dieses aktuelle Ereignisse aufgreifen, die gerade geschehen. Das ist ja eben aus Sicht der freien Information oder eben unfreien Information sehr interessant und spannend, was da abläuft, dass Zugänge zum Internet aus den jeweiligen Ländern eben gesperrt werden, nicht gesperrt werden, da bestimmte Teile vielleicht von erstmal nur gesperrt werden und wie konsequent ein Regime damit umgeht und das haben wir jetzt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten anhand vieler Länder wirklich beobachten können und auch sehen können, welche Probleme da auftreten, aber auch wie man ihnen helfen kann und da dachte ich mir, dass Herr Urbach eine sehr, sehr schöne Aktion gemacht hat mit der Gruppe Telecomix, da hat er nämlich den Leuten dort geholfen, dass sie das Telefon und Modems, nicht mehr so über DSL-Leitungen, sondern wie man das früher gemacht hat, also mit alten, technoklassischen Varianten, wie man früher ins Internet ging, dort den Leuten irgendwie Ja, ich bin ja schon in der Zeit, in der ich noch irgendwie noch zu helfen. Und die Elektra hatte in Südafrika zu Friedenszeiten, unabhängig sozusagen von einer Krisenintervention, Townships in Südafrika vernetzt durch Redner Freifunkttechnologie. Und da dachte ich, sie ist auch eine wunderbare Kandidatin, hier Rede und Antwort zu stehen, wie man denn sozusagen den Leuten, die weniger gut vernetzt sind und in solchen demokratisch schwierigen Situationen Probleme haben, helfen kann.
Jetzt ist ja sozusagen in dem Fall, also in dem Beispiel aus Südafrika, da war einfach kein Internet und da ist es hingebracht. Ich würde jetzt aber gerne, bevor wir darüber sprechen, wie wir Internet irgendwo hinbringen, tatsächlich erst nochmal erklären, wie wir das Internet vorher kaputt machen. Also das Problem bei den ganzen Staaten, wo jetzt gerade die Revolten am Start sind, ist ja, da gab es schon Internet. Und das wurde dann, je nachdem, abgeschaltet oder eingehängt oder umgeleitet, wie auch immer. Da würde ich jetzt gerne mal von euch genauer wissen, wie macht man denn so ein Internet kaputt? Also klar, die einfache Variante kann ich mir ausdenken. Irgendjemand geht zu sämtlichen Service-Providern und sagt, so, hier Stecker raus aus allen Maschinen, dann ist das Internet irgendwie auch kaputt. Wobei ich mich da schon frage, wie einfach ist das eigentlich? Kann man wirklich einen physikalischen Stecker an Maschinen ziehen und dann ist das Internet irgendwie down?
Ja, kann man.
Bei Ägypten zum Beispiel war ja zum allergrößten Teil offline, wie viel Aufwand muss man drehen? Wie vielen Leuten muss man gehen und sagen, hier Stecker raus?
Im schlimmsten Fall muss man zu einer Person gehen und ihr die Waffe in den Kopf halten und sagen, hier sieht zu, dass nichts mehr funktioniert. Im besten Fall zu unendlich vielen Personen, den haben wir natürlich noch nicht.
Wie in einer Person? Ich meine konkret am Beispiel von Ägypten, da gibt es ja ein paar Service-Provider.
Ja, es gibt ein Protokoll, das ist das Border-Rooting-Protokoll. Das sorgt dafür, dass nach außerhalb des Landes bekannt wird, wo welche IP-Adresse sich aufhält, damit die Route hergestellt werden kann.
Das heißt, ein Netzwerk ist innerhalb eines Landes relativ abgekapselt?
Teilweise, ja. In Ägypten war das so. Da wurde im Endeffekt dafür gesorgt, dass nach außen hin nicht mehr bekannt wurde, wo welche IP-Adresse sitzt, und es gab keine Routen mehr. Die Straße war weg.
Aber die Leute konnten untereinander noch kommunizieren?
Anfänglich ja, und dann wurde auch die Interkommunikation abgeschaltet. Das wurde dann auch wegkonfiguriert.
Elektra, du hattest da noch eine Anmerkung?
Bei vielen Ländern ist es so, dass man häufig nur ein oder zwei Stellen hat, wo ein Seekabel aus Übersee an der Küste anlandet. Wenn man diese Küstenstelle besetzt und da einen Filter einbaut, dann kann man effektiv die Verbindung nach außen abbürgen.
Also halten wir fest, es ist schon mal sehr einfach, ein Land vom äußeren Internet abzuschneiden. Dann können aber die Leute erstmal noch unter sich selbst kommunizieren. Eine andere spannende Geschichte, wie ich fand, ist, dass man... Libyen war das, wo man gehört hat, der Datenverkehr hat jetzt abgenommen um 20%. Heißt das einfach, die haben dann ein paar Rechner vom Netz genommen, das ist weniger geworden? Oder, ich würde sagen, in Manga ist es besser als im Vergleich, kann man wirklich die Leitung schmaler machen?
Das kann man tun, ja. Man kann die Leitung einfach schmaler machen, um zwar in dem Bild zu bleiben, das geht. Da gibt es technische Möglichkeiten für, genau das passiert gerade in Libyen.
Und wie macht man das? Kannst du es ein bisschen genauer erklären?
Ich kann einfach die Datendurchsatzraten runterschrauben. Also ich kann einem Gerät sagen, dass es nicht mehr so viel Daten entgegennehmen kann oder durchleiten darf, wie es eigentlich könnte. Also kann ich über das Protokoll des Gerätes regeln.
Sind das dann sozusagen die einzigen Möglichkeiten, oder können wir noch mehr Schindula treiben? Ach, mach mal, du kannst viel Schindula treiben. Was ist denn zum Beispiel mit dem sogenannten Kill Switch? Es gibt ja den Internet Kill Switch, da wird immer von geredet. Der eine große, hohe Schalter, bäm, drauf gedrückt, dann ist alles aus.
Ja, das hat Ägypten gemacht, diesen Kill Switch gedrückt. Das heißt, dass die Protokolle abgeschaltet oder umkonfiguriert. Da gibt es aber auch verschiedene Szenarien, wie man diesen Kill Switch benutzen könnte. Angefangen von, ich schalte wirklich physikalisch das Netz ab.
Oder ich sperre einfach den Zugang zu einer bestimmten Wettkarte, zum Beispiel Facebook oder Twitter. Und wenn viele Leute das benutzen, geht der Wandbreitenbedarf natürlich runter. Beziehungsweise der Bedarf ist immer noch der gleiche.
Ich sage irgendwie, die 100% aller Leute geht einmal am Tag auf Facebook. Ich sperre einfach diese Seite und dann ist es schon mal viel weniger Internet.
Oder der Effekt tritt auf, wenn du einfach den Zugang zu Facebook buchst.
Was man natürlich auch prüfsichtigen muss, ist die Menge der Anbindung, die ein Land in andere Länder hat. Ich erinnere mich an eine Zahl, die schon einige Jahre alt ist. Aber da hatte Deutschland selbst zum Beispiel einfach nur eine Größenordnung von 15 bis 20 physikalische Leitungen, die wirklich ins Ausland massiv benutzt wurden.
Was ja immerhin schon mal mehr ist als zwei Unterseekabel.
Ja, in der Tat. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel physikalischer Schaden angerichtet werden muss, ist das sozusagen schon kritisch.
Das ist ja auch eine ähnliche Situation in Ägypten. Da sind ja auch mehr als zwei Unterseekabel, die da rauskommen. Also die meisten Mittelmeerkabel kommen in Ägypten auch raus.
Okay, das heißt, wenn die in Verkehr abbrechen, dann ist gleich auch der Rest von Afrika mit am Start, oder? nicht mehr mit am Start?
Teile Afrikas müssen dann neu routen. Also müssen dann neue Wege finden, um dann halt die anderen Knotenpunkte zu erreichen. Das ist richtig, ja. Also was nicht mehr durch Ägypten durchgeht, muss über andere Wege gehen, um dann die anderen Unterseekabel zu erreichen.
Es gibt recht neuerdings, verhältnismäßig jetzt, ein Unterseekabel quasi um Afrika herum, welches dann jeweils Abzweigungen an die Küstenländer hat. Das gibt es aber auch noch nicht lange.
Wer sitzt da drauf?
Betreibergesellschaft bestimmt.
Bis zur Fußball-WM in Südafrika war die gesamte Ostseite von Afrika überhaupt nicht bei Kabel angebunden. Lediglich in Westafrika gab es einige Stellen, wo das Internet über Glasfaser angelandet wurde. Und in Nordafrika und in Südafrika. Und in Zentralafrika, auch in Ländern wie Tansania, war bis dato eigentlich nur Satellitenanbindung an das Internet möglich. Und diese Verbindung kann man auch nicht so einfach unterbrechen. Also die würden jetzt auch, wenn jetzt hier ein Killswitch betätigt wird, die V-Sat-Anbindungen, die werden auch weiter laufen.
Wenn ich einen Unterseekabel habe, das kommt irgendwo rein, da muss dann verteilt werden, da ist sozusagen richtig strukturnötig. Und da gibt es auch zentrale Stellen, die man beschädigen kann, also auch einfach physikalisch. Satelliteninternet, ist das dann einfacher? Also kann sich da irgendwie jeder mit seinem Wohnwagen so eine Schüssel hinstellen und sagen, ich verteile jetzt mal hier Internet?
Also gerade wenn man in der Nähe des Äquators kommt, dann braucht man dafür 3, 5 Gigahertz Satellitenanbindung. Die Schüsseln werden da sehr groß und unhandlich. Also wir reden hier über Installationen, wo die Schüssel etwa 2, 5 Meter Durchmesser hat.
Letztlich benötigst du da auch immer einen passenden Satelliten auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite oben. Und da ist die Bandbreite verhältnismäßig sehr teuer. Das heißt, soweit das in größerer Menge nachgefragt wird.
Also das heißt, es ist dann eher ein Ressourcenproblem, aber es ist nicht für jedermann verfügbar.
Man kann es dann auch wieder verteilen, aber die Bandbreiten sind dann auch nicht besonders hoch.
Kleine Zusatzinfo, in Tansania hat 2006 64 Kilobit Up und Downlink, also ein einzelner ISDN-Kanal von der Bandbreite her 1500 Dollar pro Monat gekostet.
Okay, das ist teuer. Apropos Bandbreite, wie sieht das überhaupt aus mit Bandbreite? Ab wann redet man heutzutage von jemand hat Internet?
Das ist eine schöne Frage. Kommt ganz drauf an, wo ich gerade bin. In Europa reden die meisten von einer 2M-Mitleitung. Ich habe Internet. In anderen Gegenden ist es, wenn sie eine 56K-Leitung haben.
Das war aber hier vor zehn Jahren auch noch so.
Das war hier vor zehn Jahren auch noch so. Wir sind da auch sehr verwöhnt. Wenn ich die meisten Dienste benutze, brauche ich mindestens eine 1K-Leitung. Einfach weil so viel Daten übertragen, wenn ich nur einen Web-Mailer aufrufe, bekomme ich unglaublich viel Datenmüll mit, der überhaupt nicht für die Funktionalität wichtig ist. Das ist einfach an Grafiken, an Skripten und solchen Dingen. Ich weiß, dass Menschen schon froh waren, wenn sie die 56K in den letzten Wochen gehabt haben.
Okay, komm gleich nochmal zu.
Als ich in Bangladesch war, hatte Bangladesch überhaupt keine kabelgebundene Anbindung. Also es ging alles nur über Fawzard. Und da war Yahoo-Chat die Killer-Applikation, weil man dafür nur ein Minimum an Bandbreite braucht, weil da einfach nur einfache ASCII-Text übertragen wird.
Herr Urbach hat da einen sehr interessanten Punkt angesprochen, dass eben wir durch unsere doch sehr seriösen, großzügigen Bandbreiten im Verhältnis zu eben anderen Menschen in der Welt dann auch Services entwickeln und benutzen, die sehr bandbreitend intensiv sind im Verhältnis zu dem, was andere Menschen auf dem Planeten haben. Aber was möchte ich schon? Es gibt ja sogar auch Betreiber großer Rechenzentren, die jeder von uns kennt, die warnen in Interviews sozusagen vor bestimmten Programmiersprachen, weil die so rechenintensiv sind und das sehr viel Strom verbrauchen würde. Und dass letztlich wir eigentlich nochmal den Beruf des Netzökologen ausrufen könnten.
Aber Frau Zmormann, die Frage ist, also zum Beispiel in Ägypten galt ja Facebook als ganz wichtiges Kommunikationsmittel. Und wenn ich das bei mir beobachte, wie Leute Facebook benutzen, ist das für viele Leute, die ihre Kommunikation im Internet vervielfachen, seit es Facebook gibt, einfach weil das eine Plattform ist, die so einfach zu benutzen ist. Also wo sie sich überhaupt gar keine Mühe mehr machen müssen, wo sie keine Mail-Konten einrichten müssen oder irgendwie Chat-Login-Daten wissen müssen. Und dann frage ich mich natürlich, erhöht das nicht das Mindestmaß an Bandbreite, was man braucht, um von Internet zu sprechen, weil man mit was anderem als Facebook gar nicht klarkommt. Also habt ihr so in Ägypten Daten, wie viel man da haben wollte, will?
Wir haben nicht mitgemessen, weil Telecomix glaubt nicht an Logs. Wir haben einfach keine. Wir haben Kontakte zu Menschen gehabt, die unsere Zugänge benutzt haben. Und die 56K-Zugänge haben für ihr rudimentäres Netz gereicht. Viele haben auch ihre Facebooksachen im Cache gehabt. Das heißt, es musste nicht alles neu geladen werden. Und dann würden wir wirklich nur die neuen Daten übertragen. Das war dann wohl okay für die Leute. Also wenn die Sachen erstmal im Cache sind, dann funktioniert das Ganze auch.
Das heißt, man hat die Seite schon einmal auf seinem Rechner aufgerufen und die großen bunten Bilder sind schon alle da. Und man muss noch die tatsächlichen Kommunikationsdaten übertragen. Genau das. Bevor wir jetzt genauer dahin kommen, das geht uns schon in Richtung zu sagen, wie kriegen wir das Internet wieder hin, noch eine Frage zur Beeinflussung des Netzes. Also es ist ja auch eine Strategie, um das Netz glatt zu machen, dass man nicht den Dienst abschaltet, sondern umleitet. Zum Beispiel gibt es ja den bekannten URL-Kürzungsdienst Bitly. Der sitzt ja, wie man an der Endung erkennen kann, in Libyen. Und ich habe neulich bei Twitter gelesen, wo ich gesagt habe, es ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis sozusagen jeder Link, der mit Bitly gekürzt wurde, auf Gaddafi-Seite dann. Inwiefern spielt das eine Rolle, dass nicht nur Seite dichtgemacht wird, sondern verändert?
Ich glaube, das Verändern ist noch nicht im Repertoire der unterdrückenden Regimes angekommen.
Das ist dann die hohe Schule.
Das ist der Meinungsmacher. Nur weil es ein.ly Domain ist, heißt das nicht, dass es auch in Libyen sitzt. Das ist eher noch Zukunftsmusik. Aber ich glaube auch, dass Regimes oder Diktaturen, wie zum Beispiel China traue ich das durchaus zu, solche Dinge tun. Das traue ich auch diversen anderen Diktaturen prinzipiell erst mal zu, dass Seiten nicht ans Original geliefert werden, sondern halt umgeroutet werden. Aber da kann ich mich jetzt momentan nicht versteifen an irgendwelchen Zahlen oder dergleichen. Das sind nur Vermutungen.
Das heißt aber, bei den Diktatoren, die es jetzt gerade geht, können wir froh sein, dass die Diktatoren noch nicht so viel Ahnung haben, weil die schalten einfach ab und dann kann man was gegen machen.
Das sage ich nicht ganz.
Selbst die Great Chinese Firewall ist nicht unüberwindlich. Also die Chinesen machen das routinemäßig.
Sie schalten hier wirklich ab, das heißt, wir hatten jetzt verschiedene Ebenen gehabt. Entweder nur die Punkte nach außen, man hat innerhalb des Landes noch die Möglichkeit zu kommunizieren. Oder man sagt einfach, die Provider schalten ab, damit ist auch die Möglichkeit innerhalb des Landes zu kommunizieren dahin. Das wurde auch teilweise angewandt. Und da sind die Leute erstmal auf sich selbst gestellt und müssen gucken, wie sie sich alternativ vernetzen können.
Aber genau, das ist ja der Punkt sozusagen. Die Leute wissen, okay, Internet ist jetzt aus, wir brauchen jetzt eine alternative Route. In dem Moment, wo sie sagen, es sieht nicht aus, sondern es einfach nur verändert würde, hätten das Leute schwieriger.
Es ist prinzipiell dann noch leichter umgehbar, weil wenn du jetzt sagst, man hat eine Stichwortfilter auf Google-Suchergebnisse oder...
Dann musst du aber auch erstmal wissen, dass er da ist.
Dann musst du erstmal wissen, dass der Filter da ist und dass man den vielleicht umgehen kann und wie man ihn umgeht. Aber ich denke, das ist besser, wenn man da mit einem größeren Aufwand...
Welche Sperrung ist besser? Falls ihr eine Meinung dazu habt, könnt ihr gerne Folgendes tun.
Jetzt alle rufen.
0331 70 97 110 Elektra, du meintest gerade irgendwie, in China machen sie das quasi jeden Tag, dass sie da die Feierwolle umgehen. Mir war nicht klar, dass das schon so alltäglich ist, also auch für die Internetnutzer dort. Ich dachte, das ist immer noch ein großes Geheimnis.
Das praktische Problem, was man in China hat, ist, man hat nicht genügend Bandbreite, um beispielsweise YouTube zu schauen. Also man kann die Seite zwar aufrufen, indem man sich einen Tunnel aufbaut über einen Proxy im Ausland.
Okay, kurz in einfachen Worten.
Man baut eine verschlüsselte Datenverbindung zu einem Computer außerhalb von China auf. Und dieser Computer leitet dann diese Anfragen weiter. Der chinesische Firewall kann dagegen nichts tun, weil es verschlüsselt ist. Und es geht dann halt über einen Port, den sie nicht blockieren können, weil sonst bestimmte Dinge einfach auch gar nicht mehr gehen. Sie haben jetzt schon ohnehin das Problem, dass für Geschäftsleute ist es geschäftsschädigend, was sie machen. Und die Chinesen sprechen deshalb auch spöttisch vom größten Intranet der Welt.
Aber hast du Informationen darüber, wie die sozusagen mal täglichen Umgang umgehen? Also ist es dann wirklich ganz normal, ich gehe ins Internetcafé und installiere mir erstmal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, meinen Tor um da irgendwie?
Also eine der Software, die es da gibt, die heißt, so viel ich weiß, Freeway. Das ist eine Windows-Applikation, die kann man einfach installieren. Und die macht das dann für einen. Nachteil ist halt bandbreitenintensiven Applikationen, wie beispielsweise, man kann nicht Tiananmen-Berichte von damals über YouTube anschauen, weil einfach die Bandbreiche über diese externen Proxies, also über diese Relaisestationen im Ausland, einfach nicht ausreicht. Insofern sind sie davon abgeschnitten.
Aber das ist schon zu sagen, also dieses Freeway zu benutzen, das ist quasi schon allgemein Wissen. Also nicht hin zu Kunst vielleicht, aber sozusagen schon die...
Ambitionierte Nutzer wissen sich zu helfen.
Ja, das kann ich bestätigen. Telecomix stellt auch Proxies bereit und solche Dinge. Und auch für die Chinesen natürlich.
So, ok, jetzt hast du zum zweiten oder dritten Mal Telecomix gesagt. Das hört sich für mich an wie so eine... Also Asterix hat jetzt noch einen neuen Barden im Dorf, der möglicherweise irgendwas mit Fernmusik zu tun hat. Nee, im Ernst, erklär mal, Telecomix ist ja quasi der Verein, oder die Qualle hast du es vorhin im Auto erklärt, der du angehörst. Erzähl mal ein bisschen, was das ist.
Telecomix ist ein Jellyfish Cluster, deswegen die Qualle. Wir sind ganz viele Leute aus der ganzen Welt. Ursprünglich wurde es in Schweden gegründet. Es ist ein Working Ground. Man trifft sich dort, um über Technik zu sprechen, über Methoden, um Zensur zu umgehen, um Darknets aufzubauen, Proxys anzubieten, Seiten zu mirrorn. Es gibt keine feste Struktur dergleichen. Wenn jemand eine Idee hat und die präsentiert wird, dann ist es eine Telecomix-Aktion. Ansonsten halt nicht.
Und nach welchen Kriterien wird die angenommen? Wer gerade da ist, entscheidet mit.
Ja, also es ist eine sehr flüssige Demokratie.
Okay, das klappt ja gut. Hat man auch an vielen anderen Beispielen gesehen. Gibt es irgendwelche Aktionen, mit denen man euch in Verbindung bringt, wo man jetzt vielleicht, also Telecomix haben wahrscheinlich früher noch nicht gehört, aber wo man dann sagen würde, ah ja, okay, da habe ich irgendwie was mitgeschnitten.
Ja, also zuletzt jetzt Modems für Ägypten, Modems für Libyen. Wir haben versucht oder haben es auch getan, während der Blackout in Ägypten haben wir Modemverbindungen bereitgestellt. Das heißt, wir haben in Europa und weltweit Rechner hingestellt, die Modems drin hatten, die angerufen werden konnten aus dem Ausland, die daraufhin dem Anrufenden Internetverbindungen bereitgestellt haben.
Crazy shit. Also man konnte quasi aus Ägypten euch anrufen, dann hatte man auf einmal Internet.
Genau.
Wie das genau funktioniert, das klären wir, würde ich sagen, nach den Nachrichten, wir hören jetzt erst ein Stückchen Musik. Das hat der Wetterfrosch rausgesucht. Ja, ja, es gibt einen Chat zu seiner übrigens auf isc.freenode.net und die Leute regen sich immer völlig auf, wenn wir im Chaosradio Musik spielen. Aber Wetterfrosch hat die Musik mitgebracht. Es hat irgendwas mit Döner und Candlelight zu tun. Kannst du es kurz erklären?
Das kommt aus der Hamburger Posse, wo ich eine Zeit lang da kurz war. Das wurde heute dann extra noch für die Sendung unter GreatEffCom ist der Release. Oder Fahrt glaube ich schon. Klingt ganz lustig.
Na gut, hören wir mal rein.
Aber das wüsste ich ja gar nicht, wenn du dein Stöpsel da drin hast.
Das Unglaubliche ist kassiert, ihr hört gerade Chaosradio. Das Chaosradio ist die Sendung, wo eigentlich meistens Zeugtun durchgeredet wird und wo die Leute, die im Chat zur Sendung unterwegs sind, die nur auf iac.freenote.org findet, immer total empört sind, wenn Musik gespielt wird. Die sachten jetzt tatsächlich, gar nicht so schlecht die Musik. Um Gottes Willen, was ist denn da nur los? Wir sprechen heute außerdem über Internet in Krisengebieten. Wie man Internet in Länder bekommt, wo die Mächtigen denken, hey, das schalten wir mal ab, das erklären wir gleich genauer. Vorher gibt es aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Frühlingsfreude feiern mit Kraft Club im Fritz Club.
Und das hört man...
Um kurz vor halb 12.
Und Kaietan Dürlich, den einzigen Mann im Studio ohne Rechner.
Das stimmt, bei der Bahn wird morgen wieder gestreikt. Das hat am Abend die Lokführer-Gewerkschaft GDL mitgeteilt. Falko Wittig berichtet. Nach Angaben der GDL sollen die Streiks morgen zwischen 8.30 und 11.30 stattfinden. Reisende müssen im Nah- und Fernverkehr deutschlandweit mit umfangreichen Verspätungen und Zugausfällen rechnen. Nicht betroffen ist allerdings diesmal die Berliner S-Bahn. Die GDL will sie verschonen. Die Gewerkschaft will mit dem Warnstreik für die 26.000 Lokführer in Deutschland einheitliche Lohn- und Arbeitsbedingungen durchsetzen. In Libyen greifen Chaos und Gewalt weiter um sich. Teile des Landes sind nicht mehr unter Kontrolle von Staatschef Gaddafi. Aus Städten im Westen Libyens berichten Augenzeugen, dass Gaddafis Truppen gegen Aufständische mit großer Brutalität vorgehen. Der französische Gesandte für Menschenrechte geht davon aus, dass seit Beginn des Aufstands 2000 Menschen getötet wurden. In einer wirren, telefonischen Ansprache im Staatsfernsehen machte Gaddafi das Terrornetzwerk Al-Qaeda für die Unruhen verantwortlich und beschimpfte noch einmal das eigene Volk. Die Schweiz hat am Abend angekündigt, Gaddafis Guthaben auf Schweizer Konten komplett einzufrieren. Nordrhein-Westfalen schafft zum nächsten Wintersemester die Studiengebühren ab. Das hat der Landtag mit den Stimmen der Regierungsparteien SPD und Grüne und der Oppositionellen Linken entschieden. Entschuldigung. Bislang hatten die Hochschulen von ihren Studenten pro Semester 500 Euro kassiert. Mit der Abschaffung der Studiengebühr hat NRW-Ministerpräsidentin Kraft eines ihrer großen Wahlversprechen eingelöst. Die Raumferre Discovery hat heute Abend ihre letzte Reise ins All. In etwa 20 Minuten startet sie vom Weltraumbahnhof Cape Canaveral in Florida zur ISS. Die berühmte Raumferre ist schon seit 27 Jahren im Einsatz und soll nach diesem Flug am Boden bleiben. Danach plant die NASA höchstens nur noch zwei Shuttle-Flüge. Aus Kostengründen sollen Astronauten ab Sommer mit russischen Raketen ins All fliegen. Bayer Leverkusen ist ohne Probleme in das Achtelfinale der Europa League eingezogen. Bayer Leverkusen gewann das Rückspiel der Zwischenrunde gegen den ukrainischen Club Metterle Schakow mit 2 zu 0. Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin wärtet zwischen minus 4 und minus 7 Grad. Als Kürder ist es in Brandenburg in Cottbus minus 8 Grad. Frankfurt und Angermünde minus 7, Potsdam und Neuropie minus 5, Wittenberge minus 3 Grad. Die Nacht ist wenig bewölkt und meist sternenklar. Und auch heute ist es wieder ziemlich kalt draußen. Die T-Satelligen im Laufe des Morgens dann bei minus 13 Grad. Tagsüber wechseln sich Sonne und Wolken ab. Es bleibt trocken. Die Höchstsatelligen dann am Freitag zwischen minus 4 und einem Grad plus. Drei Meldungen habe ich hier. Die kommen aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. A100 Stadtrink Richtung Knolkow und Treptow. Zwischen dem Siemensdamm und dem Dreieck Funkturm aktuell 4 Kilometer Stau. A100 Stadtrink Richtung Wedding zwischen dem Spandauer Damm und dem Dreieck Charlottenburg. Dort staute es sich aktuell auf 3 Kilometer lang. Und A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Haveland. Zwischen Dreieck Werder und Großkreuz, da ist die rechte Spur blockiert. Da liegen zwei tote Füchse auf der Fahrbahn.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Im Telekomnetz können die Behebungen von Störungen weiter andauern. Grund ist ein bundesweiter Warnstreik von rund 6.000 Mitarbeitern in Kundenzentren und im Störungsdienst. Zu dem Streik hat die Gewerkschaft Verdi vergangenen Montag aufgerufen. Und eine Meldung aus Nordafrika und anderen instabilen Regionen. Auch in den kommenden Wochen ist mit Ausfällen und Totalsperrungen zu rechnen. Wir empfehlen die Gebiete weiträumig zu umruten, da wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Und eine neue Musik im WWW an FAITZDE.
Mit Markus Richter im Chaosradio und zu Gast sind heute gleich drei Leute, nämlich der Wetterfrosch vom Chaos Computer Club, die Elektra Wagenrad ebenfalls vom Chaos Computer Club und der Herr Urbach von Telecomix. Und ihr habt es ja gerade in den Datenverkehrsmeldungen schon gehört, es ist nicht so richtig einfach derzeit in manchen Gebieten, da ist das Internet nicht ganz auf der Höhe. In Deutschland mag es noch gehen, da beschwert man sich, wenn man so zwei, drei Tage kein Internet hat, aber in Afrika oder anderen Ländern, wo es gerade hoch hergeht, da beschließen die Mächtigen gerne mal so. Also wir machen jetzt das Netz aus und dann gibt es so Leute wie Elektra und Herr Urbach, die sagen, nö, wir machen da trotzdem Netz. Mal gucken, wie das geht. Wir hatten jetzt gerade vor den Nachrichten ein bisschen angefangen, du hattest erzählt, ihr stellt irgendwo Rechner hin, also die Telecomix-Quale, so hat sich dein Verein beschrieben, und die haben Modems dran. Ich erkläre genauer.
Ja, man nimmt einen Rechner, packt einen Modem rein und wultet den dann, am besten mit einem Linus, weil da geht es am einfachsten mit, und richtet den dann so ein, dass er angerufen werden kann, also die Nummer ist ja, man hat ja seine Telefonleitung, die Nummer hat man ja normalerweise, und dass er Anrufe entgegennimmt und dann diese Anrufe nimmt und ins Netz weiter rotet.
Damit habt ihr Ägypten wieder Internet verschafft.
Genau.
Das kann nicht so einfach sein.
Also es handelt sich hier um eine Dial-Abverbindung per Modem, wie man sie früher, vor ISTN-Zeiten oder auch parallel zu ISTN-Zeiten, wenn man nur mit einem analogen Telefonanschluss geschädigt war. Da musste man dann auch immer bezahlen pro Minute, was ich schrecklich fand. Eins meiner ersten Ziele war, selbst wenn ich nur 3 Kilobyte pro Sekunde habe, möchte ich die 24 Stunden und ich möchte nicht dafür gebucht werden, dass ich jede Minute bezahlen muss. Das waren furchtbare Zeiten. Ja, es ist einfach nur Dial-Abverbindung, wie man sie früher gemacht hat. Kann man mit einem Modem machen, braucht ein spezielles Modem, was die Funktion hat, dass es auch angerufen werden kann, dass es also entgegennehmen.
Das Spannende ist, dass die meisten Modems, die heute noch existieren, das muss man ganz klar so sagen, weil eigentlich ist es ja harter Vintage-Müll und wird weggeschmissen, die meisten Modems, die noch existieren können, angerufen werden. Das ist das Schöne daran. Also das ist meistens 56k Modems. Das waren die neueren damals.
Die Spitze der technologischen Entwicklungen.
Ja, die tollen Sachen.
Ok, mal abgesehen davon, dass das anscheinend eine prima Ausrede ist, warum man in der Zukunft allen Hardware-Müll aufhebt, weil man könnte es ja möglicherweise später noch mal gebrauchen, wenn die moderne Technik nicht mehr funktioniert. Wollten wir heute auch noch die Hörer darauf hinweisen, dass sie sich gerne auch an dieser Sendung beteiligen möchten. Das können sie einerseits ganz einfach tun, und zwar so. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Aber Wetterfroschheit, das ist auch nochmal, warum?
Ja, ich würde nämlich noch gerne von den Hörern wissen, wer von euch Freunde oder Verwandte in den betroffenen Ländern wie Ägypten, Libyen, Algerien hat und irgendwie, wie ihr mit ihnen Kontakt gehalten habt in den letzten Tagen und Wochen. Ob ihr vorher mit denen vielleicht sogar per Facebook oder Twitter in Kontakt standet, das vielleicht nicht mehr ging. Ob ihr mit denen noch telefonieren konntet. Und da würde ich einfach mal gerne wissen, hat da jemand von euch ein paar Leute einig gehabt, aus dem häufig am Draht?
Also die sagen wir, die hier im Studio sitzen, wir haben nur einen relativ abstrakten Blick auf diese ganzen Sachen. Und ich verguete mal selbst der Herr Urbach, der von Telecomix, den dafür gesagt hat, dass Leute ins Netz kommen. Ihr speichert ja nichts von denen, das heißt, ihr wisst eigentlich auch nicht, wer das ist.
Wir haben am Anfang zu Debugging-Zwecken schon geschaut, wer ruft an, also woher kommt der Anruf aus welchem Land. Man sieht es ja, wenn eine Nummer übertragen wird, an der Ländervorwahl. Und auch, was tun die eigentlich grob auf, müssen wir uns einstellen. Das haben wir in Ägypten am Anfang gemacht, das haben wir auch jetzt in Libyen am Anfang gemacht. Ich glaube, ich habe es schon wieder falsch ausgesprochen.
Wer weiß, wie man das Land richtig ausspricht, der kann natürlich auch einfach Folgendes tun.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Es gibt nämlich in dem Chat zur Sendung unter irc.freenote.org oder net einfach. Ich glaube, ich habe es ganz falsch gesagt. Net oder org? Entschuldigung, Nerds im Studio? Freenote net, alles klar. Es gibt nämlich viele Leute, die sich darüber mockieren, wie wir hier Libyen aussprechen. Die sollen mal bitte anrufen und es besser machen.
So.
Also aber zu sagen, es ist für dich auch eine abstrakte Größe, diese Leute sagen. Das sind halt irgendwie, also du siehst Datenströme, die irgendwie diese Infrastruktur benutzen, die ihr aufgebaut habt. Aber du weißt, du hast auch nicht direkt Kontakt zu Leuten gehabt, die das benutzt haben.
Doch, hatten wir dann auch. Die sind, wir haben ja immer darum gebeten, wer Verbindungen aus diesen Ländern ins Netz aufbauen kann, soll sich bei Telecomix melden. Wir haben da ein Webchat-Interface, das mit wenig Datenübertragung auskommt. Und wir hatten da auch Meldungen von Ägypten und jetzt auch von Libyen. Von Krisengebietlern. Und die haben uns halt auch gesagt, ich bin gerade über eure Verbindung online und das ist total super. Und danke, dass ihr das macht. Waren meist noch nach ein paar Minuten wieder weg gewesen. Aber das war so immer wieder so eine Beschäftigung. Ja, was wir hier tun, ist gerade für diese Menschen, die die Verbindung benutzen, wichtig und richtig.
Und jetzt hast du gerade erklärt, ihr habt das gemacht, indem ihr so sagen, ich sage mal jetzt einfach so in den Rechner Modem dran gestöpselt, das Modem kann angerufen werden und dann baut das Modem über den Rechner Internetverbindung auf, dann kann der Typ, der angerufen hat, damit ins Internet, genau wie früher, TM. Jetzt stellt sich mir die Frage, okay, das heißt aber, ich habe genau pro Rechner und Modem einen Typen, der ins Internet kann. Wie viele Tausend Rechner habt ihr in welchem Lagerhaus stehen, um ganze Ägypten online zu bringen?
Wir hatten bei Ägypten zu unseren besten Zeiten ungefähr 600 Leitungen gehabt. Das war aber auch dank dem Friendstater Transit Network.
Den bitte was?
Das ist ein Provider in Frankreich, das Friendstater Transit Network. Die haben ihre alten Modembänke entstaubt und haben die wieder in Betrieb genommen. Dank dem Verein Free.de, die sitzen in Düsseldorf, die haben 30 Leitungen bereitgestellt, also eine Nummer und hinter 30 Leitungen. Und da hatten wir noch einen Provider in Holland, der das auch gemacht hat, weil seine alte Modembank entstaubt und so hatten wir mit einer Nummer natürlich möglicher, dass da mehr Leute online gehen konnten, wie das auch Free.de Telecom gemacht hat mit ihren Modemverbindungen oder auch Mondays Monday 2 damals noch. Also es war jetzt nicht immer, dass nur eine Leitung dahinter war, sondern oft waren auch mehrere Leitungen dahinter.
Und das hört sich ja trotzdem so ein bisschen für mich an, wie das könnte man auch als Homebrew Projekt machen. Also man könnte sagen, ich habe noch eine freie ESDN-Leitung rumzufliegen, hier habe ich das irgendwie angesteppelt, kann ich da mitmachen?
Ja genau.
Das geht?
Das geht. Wie? Da haben wir so ein schickes Wiki, da steht alles drin.
Im Prinzip ist es ja der böse W-Wort gesagt. Der Wohl-Schnittsbürger hat ja seine DSL-Leitung und irgendwie ESDN mit zwei Leitungen und oder analog dazu. Das heißt, häufig mal ein oder zwei Leitungen, die er eigentlich nicht braucht, wenn er nur telefonieren und surfen will. Und wenn man diese eben an einem Computer anschließt, ob jetzt mit einem Modem dazwischen oder einer ESDN-Karte wie früher, dann kann man mit einem entsprechend konfigurierten Linux-System und im Wiki von Telecomix gibt es da die nur zwei- oder dreiseitigen Anleitungen. Also das war schon relativ praktisch. Oder halt auch in den Chat von den Leuten, die, glaube ich, gerne helfen, irgendwie, da kann man ja auch mal gucken, ob es jemanden im Umfeld gibt, der vielleicht vorbeikommen mag.
Also ich wollte gerade fragen, weil es gibt ja die eine Hälfte der Leute, die diese Sendung haben, die empfinden, das Einrichten eines neuen Rechners als sozusagen hobbymäßige Herausforderungen. Und je schwieriger, desto geiler. Und dann gibt es die anderen, die sagen, super Projekt, ich würde es auch recht gerne machen, aber ich habe keinen Plan. Können wir bitte sozusagen ein, ich drücke auf einen Maus und das installiert sich von selber ein Ding zusammenbasteln?
Das basteln wir gerade. Ja, wir sind noch nicht fertig damit, das ist das Problem, weil es ist wie immer so viele Dinge, so wenig Zeit. Der Plan ist es, dass man nachher einen USB-Stick hat, den reinsteckt, dann von diesem USB-Stick bootet und alles funktioniert. Das ist der Plan, daran arbeiten wir gerade, daran arbeiten gerade mehrere Leute. Ist aber nicht so einfach, weil nicht jedes Modell mag jede Konfiguration und man muss das alles abfangen. Das ist ein Riesen-Ufriss, aber der ist es wert, unserer Meinung nach. Ansonsten, chat.telecomix.org, der Raum dial-up, da lunger ich drin rum und auch viele andere, die Ahnung haben und wir helfen gerne den ganzen Tag lang.
Jetzt befinden wir uns ja nun in Deutschland und fragt natürlich der besorgte Datenbürger als erstes so, okay, ich stell jetzt jemand anders meine Internetverbindung zur Verfügung. Mach ich mich damit nicht traf, wa?
Keine Ahnung. Ist mir persönlich auch völlig egal, aber auch da haben wir vorgesorgt. Wir haben natürlich auch noch ein weiteres Team bei Telecomix, die Proxys bereitstellen und Direktorverbindungen. Also man kann es so einstellen, dass nachher die IP, dasjenigen, der den Rechner zur Verfügung stellt, nicht mehr zu erkennen ist.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich dann für den Optionalbürgern nicht so einfach. Der sollte dann bitte auf unseren USB-Stick warten.
Also wäre die einzige Frage noch, ob mir die Telekommunikationsfirma ein Trick draus dreht, wenn Leute bei mir anrufen, aber die ausgehende Datenverbindung dürfte denen egal sein, oder?
Das ist mir völlig egal, weil ich habe meine ASL-Leitung, die darf ich benutzen, wie ich möchte. Ich darf auch da meine drei Rechner dran hängen, rein theoretisch.
Ja, klar, dann kriegst du eine Kündigung, wo dann drin steht, hier Datenverbrauch entspricht nicht dem Landesdurchschnitt. Aber egal.
Diese 56k machen fast nichts aus.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Also der Bandbreitenkonsum ist minimal. Es ist entsetzlich langsam, aber wenn halt nichts anderes geht, dann...
Ja, dann ist es sagen, gut genug. Okay, 600 Leitungen, man kann sie im Prinzip auch zu Hause hin basteln. Wie lange hat das für Ägypten gedauert, das auf die Beine zu stellen?
Wir wurden ja völlig überrascht davon. Also es hat ja damit keiner gerechnet gehabt. Also wir haben diese Drohung seit Monaten im Raum schweben, weltweit. In den USA gab es ein Gesetz, das zum Glück abgelehnt worden ist. In Deutschland reden Politiker darüber, dass sie das gerne hätten. Es war aber immer so weit weg und plötzlich steht da ein Diktator und meint, jetzt mache ich das. Und wir so, oh, keine Ahnung, was ist denn hier los? Ja und also wir hatten dann als erstes einen Rechner in Schweden stehen gehabt, mit zwei Leitungen dahinter. Das war der erste Telecomix-Styling-Server.
Der kommt jetzt ins Museum?
Hoffentlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der noch gerade noch läuft, muss ich mal nachgucken. Und dann ist halt das FDN, das French Data Transit Network, recht schnell nachgezogen, zum Glück mit recht vielen Leitungen.
Wie seid ihr herangekommen? Habt ihr Connections? Oder haben die von einem Projekt erfahren?
Da lungert einer bei uns rum. Das haben wir auch nicht gewusst, Frau Hell.
Verstehe, na schön.
Und dann auch den Verein, die Leute von Free.de sind dann auch recht schnell, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es passiert ist, aber die waren plötzlich so im Kontakt und haben halt gesprochen. Dadurch ist es halt auch recht fix gegangen. Wir hatten dann noch ein paar sehr, sehr engagierte Leute, die auch anderen halt echt wirklich Schritt für Schritt geholfen haben, wie sie ihren Rechner aufsetzen müssen. Und dann haben wir dann lange Faxe geschrieben, wo die Nummern drauf standen und die Login-Daten und haben die nach…
Okay, warte, es ist noch eine ganz spannende Frage zu sagen, woher wissen die Leute, die gar kein Netz mehr haben, wo sie hingehen müssen, um dann doch wieder ins Netz zu kommen. Die Informationen müssen irgendwie dahin kommen. Ich würde aber, bevor wir darauf ausgehen, gerne noch mal auf die Hardware zu sprechen kommen und das auch Elektra mal fragen wollen. Weil im Prinzip geht es ja bei diesem ganzen Projekt um so eine Art Minimal-Hardware. Also sagen, was brauche ich mindestens, damit das irgendwie funktioniert. Und vielleicht könntest du, Elektra, mal kurz das beschreiben, was du in Süd-Afrika gemacht hast. Vielleicht ergibt es dir am Ende so eine Art Zusammen-Dingens.
Nee, das ist grundsätzlich verschieden. Also meine Expertise sind selbst organisierende drahtlose Netze, wo man Geräte hat, die im Peer-to-Peer-Modus drahtlos arbeiten. Also wo ein Gerät sich direkt mit einem anderen drahtlos verbinden kann. Also im Gegensatz zu einem Infrastrukturmodus. Wenn wir beide mit unserem Mobiltelefon auf einem Gletscher in Island unterwegs sind, wo es keine Anbindung gibt, können wir mit dem Telefon nicht miteinander kommunizieren, weil wir keine Basisstation haben. Es gibt aber im WLAN einen Modus, wo diese Geräte direkt miteinander kommunizieren können. Also ohne, dass sie auf eine Infrastruktur angewiesen sind. Da kann man dann kommunizieren innerhalb der Reichweite der drahtlosen Interfaces. Diese Reichweite kann man verlängern, indem jedes Gerät für jedes andere Gerät im Bedarfsfall die Daten weiterreichen kann. Dann bildet sich so eine Wolke, so ein Schwarm, und in diesem Schwarm kann man dann miteinander kommunizieren. Und diese Technik setzen wir unter anderem in Süd-Afrika ein.
Aber warum ich jetzt auf die Idee gekommen bin, ist es möglicherweise, wenn wir zusammenrechnen, letztendlich wollt ihr doch schon irgendwie ins Internet oder gar nicht?
Ja, wollen wir. Aber nicht notwendigerweise. Es gibt diese Netze auch. Also wir haben eine Installation in Ost-Timo und die sind überhaupt nicht ans Internet angebunden. Da geht es nur darum, dass diese Geräte, die wir entwickelt haben, die sogenannte Mesh-Potato, die hat einen analogen Telefonanschluss. Also da kann man ein analoges Telefon, was schnurgebunden ist, kann man in dieses Gerät einstecken und da fällt dann quasi der Telefonanschluss, den man sonst von der Deutschen Telekom oder von sonst wer her kriegt, der fällt dann da raus und über den kann man dann einfach zwischen den Geräten Gespräche führen. Man kann einfach sagen, ok, ich weiß, irgendwo am anderen Ende der Stadt, da wohnt einer, dessen IP-Adresse endet auf 213, dann wähle ich 213 und dann klingelt bei ihm das Telefon. Und die Infrastruktur besteht aus den Geräten, die die Leute benutzen. Also man kann natürlich, um den Service zu verbessern, noch hohe Antennen aufstellen und Richtfunkverbindungen einrichten, aber erstmal funktioniert diese Technologie halt auch ohne Infrastruktur und die Geräte, die die Leute benutzen, um das Netz zu konsumieren, sind gleichzeitig die Infrastruktur des Netzes.
Aber wie weit reicht denn so eine einzelne Station?
Und das ist ein bisschen komplizierter zu erklären. Also da gibt es physikalische Effekte, also geben wir mal vom Idealfall aus, ich habe ein hohes Gebäude mit freier Sicht in alle Richtungen und zwei Kilometer weiter ist noch eins, dann können die Geräte ohne zusätzliche Antennen direkt miteinander kommunizieren.
Okay, aber der Standardfall ist ja, ich sitze in irgendeinem Haus in der Wohnung und möchte auch sozusagen zum Telefonieren nicht auf den Balkon gehen.
Deswegen sind die Geräte, die wir entwickelt haben, in wetterfestem Plastik eingebaut und wasserdicht. Und die Anwendung ist, wenn man irgendwo wohnt, man macht sich einen primitiven Mast, also Metallrohr oder macht das an das vorhandene Rohr von seiner Fernsehantenne dran und einfach mit zwei Kabelbindern und führt dann das Kabel in die Wohnung und dann ist dann diese Anbindung.
Das ist dann tatsächlich wie ein Telefonanschluss, also ich packe diesen Kasten auf meinen Dach und habe im Haus mein Telefon und das funktioniert jetzt großartig.
Ja, dezentral, selbstorganisierend und kostenlos.
Wenn man das Gerät hat. Und das könnte man nicht irgendwie verbinden mit irgendwie, man macht noch so einen kleinen Einwahlknoten, dann haben wir alle irgendwie auch Netz nach außen?
Doch, natürlich, aber es funktioniert halt eben auch ohne. Und deswegen ist es auch interessant für Katastrophenbereiche, wo gerade eine Naturkatastrophe eingetreten ist, die Infrastruktur kollabiert ist. Die Geräte sind so gebaut, dass sie mit einem minimalen Stromverbrauch, also wir reden hier von etwa 2, 5 Watt Auskommen, also sie haben einen weiten Eingangsspannungsbereich, also man kann alle möglichen Arten von Batterien, Stromquellen, Solarmodul, Windrad dranhängen und dann läuft der Laden.
Selber treten und dabei telefonieren.
Das geht auch.
Du hast jetzt Ost-Timo schon erwähnt, wo ist das zum Einsatz gekommen noch?
Wir sind im Moment in der Testphase. Das erste größere Testnetz ist in Ost-Timo bzw. da gibt es zwei mittlerweile und in Südafrika gibt es mehrere Netze. Einmal in Kapstadt, in Bokar und in Orange Farm, das ist eine Township, die ist 45 Kilometer außerhalb von Johannesburg.
Und das, so sagen, funktioniert dann aber immer nur im Bereich einer Örtlichkeit, sage ich mal?
Ja, aber zum Beispiel die Township in Orange Farm, die ist angebunden an das Internet über eine WLAN-Richtfunksstrecke bis nach Johannesburg. Und darüber können dann die Leute auch telefonieren und haben auch zum ersten Mal in Südafrika einen Festnetzanschluss und eine Festnetz-Telefonnummer, was unter anderem den interessanten Effekt hat, dass man viel leichter einen Job kriegt. Also wenn man nur mit einer Mobiltelefonnummer ankommt und nach einem Job sucht, dann wird man schlechter angesehen, als wenn man einen Festnetzanschluss hat. Und das ist für die dann zum ersten Mal möglich.
Aber wie geschieht das? Haben die da auch ein normales Telefonnetz? Und das kommuniziert irgendwie mit diesen zerschampften Kartoffeln?
Ich habe das vergessen zu erwähnen, es handelt sich natürlich um Voice-over-IP. Aber der Provider, Dabba Telekom, der operiert in den Townships und die stellen Festnetznummern aus dem südafrikanischen Telefonnetz bereit über Voice-over-IP.
Dann braucht es aber an einer gewissen Stelle schon wieder eine Schnittstelle zur Infrastruktur.
Da gibt es dann einen Internetanschluss und einen Server, der auch die Abrechnung managt. Das ist sehr interessant, weil die Gebühren sehr niedrig sind. Südafrika ist extrem teuer fürs Telefonieren. Die Preise sind ungefähr auf dem Niveau wie bei uns Mobiltelefonie vor etwa 5-6 Jahren. Aber die Einkommen sind sehr niedrig. Also wer Sozialhilfe empfängt, wenn man das überhaupt hinkriegt, weil viele Leute keine Papiere haben, die leben von etwa 80 Euro im Monat. Und Leute, die einen Job haben als Wachmann oder so, die verdienen zwischen 120 und 170 Euro im Monat.
Nicht allzu viel. Also wie wird das Projekt finanziert?
Das Projekt wird finanziert von Mark Shuttelworth unter anderem. Mark Shuttelworth, der Gründer von Ubuntu, der erste Mensch, der aus Afrika in den Weltraum geflogen ist. Deswegen nennt man ihn in Südafrika Afronaut und von IDRC. Das ist eine kanadische Organisation, die wird von der kanadischen Regierung finanziert, die sich damit beschäftigt, durch Technologie, Entwicklungsländern unter die Arme zu greifen.
Und das ist natürlich ein Einsatz, das kann man sich vorstellen, also Katastrophengebiete, hast du auch schon gesagt. Gibt es noch andere Einsatzszenarien, die schon erforscht werden möglicherweise?
Während wir die verschiedenen Prototypenphasen von Geräten durchgemacht haben, haben wir etwa 167 Geräte verteilt, die wurden verschickt in alle Welt an Leute, die die Geräte ausprobieren und in ihre Netze integrieren. Also Netze mit diesen Geräten gibt es an vielen Orten, überall auf der Welt verteilt, aber die größeren Installationen konzentrieren sich im Moment auf Südafrika und Ost-Himo.
Und jetzt, es handelt sich dabei tatsächlich auch um Computer. Und das hört sich für mich dann wie, das muss für jeden benutzbar sein. Ich mache das Ding an, muss dann aber irgendwie, du sagst schon irgendwie eine IP-Adresse nennen, wenn ich jemand anrufen will, wie macht das? Du hast es vorhin gezeigt, es hat keinen Monitor, sondern es hat nur ein paar Leuchtelichter. Wie richte ich das denn ein? Also geht da nie was kaputt? Habt ihr es tatsächlich geschafft, die Maschine zu bauen, die niemals kaputt geht?
Die Geräte laufen sehr zuverlässig und falls mal eine Störung auftritt, dann starten sie sich automatisch neu.
Okay, und damit ist sozusagen 99 Prozent aller Fälle abgedeckt.
Genau, die Geräte, wenn man sie quasi aus einer Kiste herausnimmt, haben eine Standardkonfiguration und jedes Gerät hat eine individuelle IP-Adresse. Und diese IP-Adresse ist auch das einzige, was man, wenn man minimale Anforderungen hat, konfigurieren kann oder sollte. Das kann man unter anderem über das Telefon machen. Also es gibt ein interaktives Sprachmenü. Im englischen Sprachraum sagt man IVR, Interactive Voice Recorded.
Also das Ding, was ich auch irgendwie dran bekomme, wenn ich die Fahrkartenauskunft und meine Bank anrufe.
Ganz genau.
Bitte drücken Sie 1.
Es gibt zwei Versionen von der Firmware. Einmal für so Voice over IP-Anbieter, da kann man weniger konfigurieren über das Telefon und die End-User-Firmware, wo man sehr weit gehen kann. Also man kann einfach das Telefon abnehmen, dann auf der Tastatur einfach MENU drücken, Menu, und dann ist man im Menü und dann kann man die entsprechenden Untermenüs aufrufen, kann sagen, ich möchte die IP-Adresse einstellen, und dann drückt man 10 Sternchen, 130 Sternchen, 1 Sternchen, 20, dann startet die Kiste neu und hat dann diese IP-Adresse.
Unglaublich.
Mir scheint, da hat jemand nachgedacht.
Das ist total großartig, ich habe das vorhin zum ersten Mal gesehen. Ich bin total begeistert davon.
Naja, es geht sehr viel weiter. Es ist Open Source. Man kann es natürlich auch über einen Computer bedienen. Da kann man dann komplexere Operationen machen. Aber wenn man jetzt einfach nur irgendwo ein Telefonnetz aufbauen will, was robust ist und schnell auszurollen ist, kann man einfach die Geräte aus dem Karton nehmen und mit Strom versorgen.
Wie viel kostet ein so ein Gerät?
Wir haben im Moment noch kleinere Stückzahlen. Also produziert wurden insgesamt etwa 1000 im Moment. Die nächste Bestellung wird um die 3000 sein. Die Prototypen waren noch relativ teuer, die haben 100 Dollar gekostet. Mittlerweile dürfte sich der Preis auf 70 Dollar reduzieren.
Okay, aber das ist natürlich dann immer noch nicht leistbar für Leute. Das wird dann über so eine Projekte wie von dem Markt Shuttlebirds gerockt?
Das ist in der Tat die Frage, ob die ganze Geschichte losrockt und den Planeten erobert. Wir werden sehen. Der Preis wird auf jeden Fall im Laufe der Zeit immer weiter sinken. Es wird vielleicht auch irgendwann ein neues Hardware-Design geben, was noch weniger Geld kostet. Wenn man erst mal angefangen hat, etwas zu entwickeln, dann findet man auch Möglichkeiten, das weiter zu minimieren und die Kosten weiter zu senken.
Jetzt wissen wir, du Elektra Wagenrad hast irgendwie da mitgefrickelt und Mark Shuttlebirds hängt irgendwie mit drin. Aber gibt es dann eine Anlaufstelle, womöglich man sich genau über dieses Projekt informieren kann und möglicherweise auch einer helfenden Hand reichen?
Exzellente Frage. Also die helfende Hand bin unter anderem ich. Der Anlaufstelle ist die Webseite www.village.telco.org. Also die Mesh-Potato ist quasi das Endgerät für die Village Telco. Die Village Telco versteht sich als ein Projekt, was einen Toolkit, also einen Baukasten entwickelt, mit dem jemand in unterentwickelten Regionen oder wo auch immer auf der Welt ein Telefoniesystem ausrollen kann, was aber nicht nur Telefonie anbieten kann. Es gibt natürlich auch einen Anschluss für Internet, also Internet und kann man darüber auch bereitstellen. Es gibt da eine Diskussionsliste auf Google, eine Google Group. Ich bin unter anderem dafür da, Support zu leisten.
Okay, also wenn man Fragen hat, kann man sie auch einfach an dich wenden. Wenn man nach dem Namen sucht, der ist wahrscheinlich auch relativ weit oben in den Sucher gebt.
Zwangsläufig. Also einfach nach willitschteleco.org schauen oder einfach nach WillitschTeleco suchen, das findet man sofort. Oder MeshPotato, wobei Mesh wird mit M-E-S-H geschrieben. Also es ist nicht die zerstampfte Kartoffel, sondern die vermaschte Kartoffel.
Alles klar, ich muss jetzt bei dem Ganzen immer an diesen, es gab früher mal dieses Projekt One Laptop per Child denken, der irgendwie auch das Ziel hatte, so 100 Dollar oder weniger und alles vernetzt und mit so einem komischen Netzwerk was untereinander funktioniert. Habt ihr irgendwelche Schnittpunkte oder ist das was völlig anderes? Was hältst du davon?
Nein, es gibt eine sehr große Überschneidung, allerdings nicht personeller Natur. Also natürlich gibt es Entwickler, die ich kenne, die für das OLPC-Projekt gearbeitet haben, aber ich arbeite jetzt selber nicht für das OLPC-Projekt. Aber wir haben im Prinzip das gleiche im Schilde. Also das OLPC-Projekt soll jedem Kind einen Computer als Bildungshilfe geben und wir arbeiten an der Kommunikations-Infrastruktur. Und man kann natürlich auch den One Laptop per Child in dieses Netz auch integrieren, das ist auch möglich.
Das geht alles irgendwie zusammen. Kreative Ansätze, um Internet dahin zu bringen, wo es es nicht mehr gibt und wo es es noch nicht gibt, gibt es jede Menge. Wir haben jetzt zwei gehört, wir werden jetzt noch ein bisschen ausführlicher beschäftigt. Einen kleinen Ausdruck würde ich jetzt gerne machen in Speak to Tweet. Wer erklärt, was das ist und wie es funktioniert und überhaupt?
Das macht der Wetterfrosch.
Das macht der Wetterfrosch. Wetterfrosch.
Das habe ich angeschleppt. Das ist, ich glaube, ein von Google eingerichteter Service, der eine Telefonnummer bereitstellt, wo Leute anrufen können, die jetzt kein Internet mehr haben. Und dort wird ihr Anruf aufgezeichnet, dort wird eine Audiodatei aufgenommen und diese getwittert. Also ein Link zu einer Seite, wo man sich die Datei direkt anhören kann. Und so wird sozusagen Menschen, die kein Internetzugang, aber noch ein Telefonzugang haben, die Möglichkeit gegeben, zu twittern. Und diese Nachrichten landen dann erst einmal als kleine Audioschnipsel in der großen Twitterwelt.
Das hört sich dann zum Beispiel ungefähr so an. Das Bezeichnende an diesem Projekt ist, dass genau das da passiert. Also es sind ganz viele Nachrichten, die irgendwie arabisch irgendwie klingen, wo keiner von uns genau weiß, was die da sagen. Und was ich mich auch frage ist, dass jetzt so ein technisch interessierter Nutzer, denkt man so, hey, geil, hat jemand Gedanken gemacht, man kann jetzt twittern über das Telefon, das ist doch irgendwie super. Ich frage mich, ob das wirklich einen Nutzen hat. Also falls da draußen jetzt jemand ist, der jemand kennt, der dieses Projekt benutzt hat oder der jetzt vielleicht uns helfen kann, was diese Speak to Tweets, die wir hier haben, was die bedeuten, dann gerne jetzt anrufen. Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 Weil mir ist es sozusagen wirklich nicht klar, wie viel das tatsächlich bringt. Also im Sinne von, was macht das? Habt ihr da irgendwie weitere Geschichten gehört? Ja, Herr Urbach? Ja, ur-bahn.
Ur-bahn, stimmt. Wir haben einige dieser Tweets übersetzt gehabt. Also gerade in der Anfangszeit haben die dann die Textzeilen getwittert dazu. Und da waren schon einfach Nachrichten dabei, wie danke, dass ihr uns unterstützt. Bis hin, Hilfe, hier fallen Schüsse. War also ziemlich alles dabei. Und natürlich auch die obligatorischen, ich grüße meine Eltern in der Heimat grüße, auch die waren dabei gewesen. Ich fand das sehr, sehr spannend. Leider kann ich kein Arabisch, aber wir hatten bei Telecomix zu dem Zeitpunkt ein paar Leute, die Arabisch konnten, die uns übersetzt haben. Das war schon teilweise auch sehr beeindruckend einfach zu hören.
Und von den Sachen, die du erlebt hast, sagen, das hört sich für mich so an, als ob der größte Effekt dieser Einrichtung wäre, dass die Leute in Sprache haben. Also es geht nicht so sehr darum, dass tatsächlich da Informationen übertragen werden, sondern einfach das Gefühl für die Leute, wir haben noch eine Verbindung nach außen. Ist das wertvoll an diesem Ding?
Das ist generell an dieser ganzen Modemaktion und auch an diesem Speech-to-Tweet-Ding das Wertvolle, dass die Menschen sich mitteilen können. Wir sind es gewohnt in unserer heutigen Welt, dass wir jederzeit uns nach außen mitteilen können. Und zwar über Landesgrenzen hinweg. Das ging nicht mehr. Und damit hatten die Menschen auch eine Möglichkeit dazu gehabt, in die Welt rauszuschreien, was sie beschäftigt, was sie bedrückt, was sie erfreut. Wir leben in einer Welt, in der der Mensch immer mehr dazu übergeht, ganz weit zu streuen, was er mitteilen möchte. Und diese Möglichkeit haben wir den Leuten gegeben. Und vor allem fand ich da sehr großartig einfach daran, dass da schnell reagiert worden ist. Also Google hatte diesen Service erst zwei Wochen vorher gekauft gehabt.
Genau, so eine Telefonie, irgendwas Service, Sprachentsatz.
Das war dann so ein Wochenendprojekt von so einem Google-Entwickler, dass er das mal schnell baut, hat sich mit zwei Twitter-Leuten zusammengesetzt und die haben es mal gebastelt halt. Ich fand es einfach schön zu sehen, dass Menschen da sind, weltweit, die sich Gedanken machen, wie kann man die Lebensqualität der Menschen vor Ort entweder halbwegs aufrechterhalten oder zumindest versuchen zu verbessern.
Also eine kleine Leitung nach außen, obwohl die Mächtigen des Landes beschlossen haben, das sollt ihr eigentlich nicht mehr können, wir wollen euch eigentlich mal alles abschalten. Das ist genau das, was wir heute hier in dieser Sendung besprechen. Und von den Zweien bleibt uns noch eine im Chaosradio, heute mit Wetterfrosch, Elektra Wagenrad und Herrn Urbach. Es geht um Internet in Krisengebieten, das heißt Gebiete, wo beschlossen wurde, hey, hier soll keiner mehr kommunizieren können, dort doch noch genau das irgendwie möglich zu machen. Wir haben heute schon ein paar Ansätze gehört. Es ging mit Mesh-Netzwerken, also einfach Plastikkisten ins Land geworfen werden, die kommunizieren dann wie magisch untereinander oder alte Rechner mit Modems werden in irgendwelche Lagerhallen gestellt und können angerufen werden. Und wir haben gehört, dass in einem Wochenende ein Dienst gebaut wurde, wo man einfach anrufen kann und dann zu twittern. Es geht also um kreative Lösungen, wie Kommunikation aufrechterhalten werden kann, wie Infrastruktur für Kommunikation gebaut werden kann. Und eigentlich seid auch ihr gefragt, ruft bitte an, wenn ihr auch ein Beispiel für so einen kreativen Umgang mit Technik habt. Und während ihr das tut, werden wir noch eine weitere Musik hören. Die hat der Herr Urbach rausgesucht und ich habe schon wieder vergessen, irgendwas mit schwedischem Tanzorchester war es.
Das ist das Diablo Swing Orchestra mit dem Ballrock Boogie.
Und was ist genau was? Es ist auf jeden Fall Creative Commons Musik, weil das muss es sein, um hier in der Sendung gespielt zu werden.
Musik aus Schweden, von daher hinreichend wahnsinnig, wie ich so in schwedischer Musik gewohnt bin. Ich habe mir meine Chefin vor ein paar Jahren hingeknallt, mach mal da Werbetext, für habe ich gemacht und ja.
Ach ja, also hinreichend wahnsinnig. Hinreichend wahnsinnig ist ein schönes Prädikat, das ich in Zukunft öfter vergeben möchte. Vom Diablo-Swinger-Kristall, der Balrog-Boogie hier im Chaosradio Aufritz, empfohlen von Herrn Urbach, der meinte, er müsste mal ein bisschen schwedisch Musik hier zu Gehör bringen. Wir sprechen aber über andere Krisen, nämlich über Krisen, wo es kein Internet mehr gibt. Wir haben halt schon auch vorgestellt ein Projekt, um Internet in Gegner zu bringen oder nicht Internet. Eigentlich geht es darum, Kommunikationen in die Gegner zu bringen mittels eines, wie heißt es Elektra, Village Talks, Village Telco?
Meshpoteto heißt das Gerät und das Projekt heißt Village Telco. Die Webseite ist villagetelco.org. Übrigens habe ich vergessen, darauf hinzuweisen, es gibt ein One-Minute-Explainer-Video auf YouTube, das ist verlinkt von der Webseite, das ist großartig, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Eine Minute Zeit, dann habt ihr es auf jeden Fall verstanden. Und Reinhard angerufen hat eine kurze Frage. Hallo und guten Abend.
Eine zweite Frage, die sich noch eben ergeben hat. Wie heißt der Titel, mit dem ich das bei YouTube finden kann? Die andere Sache ist, ich habe unter Village Telco nachgeguckt im Internet und habe euch nur in Englisch gefunden.
Habt ihr noch irgendwie eine deutsche Seite? Die dritte Sache ist, mit welcher Hardware arbeitet er zentral mit diesem WLAN-Funkchip? Gut, also es sind internationale Anstrengungen, diese Entwicklung. Sie richtet sich nicht speziell an Deutschland, deswegen gibt es keine deutsche Seite. Es ist leider alles in Englisch.
Aber man könnte sich durchaus hinstellen und das mal übersetzen, oder?
Ja, könnte man tun. Aber Deutschland ist eben kein Entwicklungsgebiet, von daher konzentrieren wir uns da nicht drauf. Die andere Frage ist der Chip, der da innen drin, das ist ein Single-Chip-System, also ein SoC, System on Chip. Und der stammt von der Firma Ateros. Der kann WLAN nach 800, 2.11, B und G.
Rainer, Fragen beantwortet?
Eine Zusatzfrage, wenn ich nachhaken darf, technisch. Es gibt diesen einen Big-C-C-Chip.
Okay, nein, nein, nein. Das wird zu technisch, das wird für alle anderen, die jetzt am Radio, am Rundfunk, am Fankstrieger sitzen, können dann nicht mehr folgen. Stell die Frage einfach hier direkt, du kannst ja auf die Webseite gehen und dann deine Mail schreiben, okay? Danke. Also ihr könnt gerne anrufen, wenn ihr Fragen habt, das ist wirklich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Aber wir sollten schon sagen, im Rahmen dessen bleiben, dass wir zumindest halbwegs dem Gespräch folgen können. Aber dann gilt wie gesagt gerne. 0331 70 97 110 Genau, über tiefergehende technische Gespräche wollen wir uns allerdings dann an dieser Stelle nicht auslassen. Was immer noch so bedeutet, die Kontakt haben zu Leuten, die in Libyen oder Ägypten jetzt sitzen oder gesessen haben und dort mal über die Situation berichten können.
Oder in China.
Oder in China zum Beispiel. Die Leute, die in China schon mal waren, das finde ich auch immer spannend. Ich habe es bis jetzt noch von Einanlo gehört und das auch noch ganz kurz. Aber so Leute, die in China waren, dort mal das Internet erlebt haben. Das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren.
Na, da kann ich die unterstehen.
Ah, okay, warum sagt ihr das nicht gleich?
Ich glaube, ich hatte es voll schon.
Also jetzt ist es natürlich so, eigentlich sollen die Leute anrufen. Aber gut, erzähl mal.
Nein, du warst noch nicht da, die Leute sollen anrufen.
Also wir können jetzt ja auf einen Anruf warten oder...
Während ihr anruft, erzählt Elektra schon mal, was sie in China erlebt hat.
Also ich war in Shenzhen, das ist in der Nähe von Hongkong und ich war in Weijing. Ich habe das Internet benutzt, vor allem über das Mobiltelefon. Das funktioniert sehr gut und ist auch sehr, sehr preiswert, muss ich sagen. Man kriegt da eine GPS-Verbindung und die Gebühren sind sehr, sehr niedrig. Man kann erstaunlicherweise die gesamte westliche Presse in der englischen Sprache lesen. Das ist kein Problem. Man kann auch Dinge mit Google suchen, wobei die Chinesen ihre eigene Suchmaschine haben, die heißt Baidu.
Die sind aber auch powered bei Google, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, nein. Das haben sie nicht.
Das ist eine eigene Entwicklung.
Das ist auch ein Konkurrenzprodukt. Man kann die gesamten westlichen Medien lesen. Allerdings, die Seite, die man nicht aufrufen kann, ist die von Chaos Computer Club, die ist blockiert. Und alles, was mit Wiki drin ist, kann man auch nicht aufrufen, weil da könnte jemand eigene Inhalte einbringen, die dann andere Leute sehen und das will man nicht haben. Und deswegen geht auch die Village Telco Google Group, die kann man zum Beispiel vom chinesischen Internet aus auch nicht lesen.
Wie ist das mit so Tettdiensten?
Hab ich auch verwendet. Jabbah geht wunderbar, kein Problem.
Okay, wo ist jetzt die große Firewall, von der wir alle sprechen? Entschuldigung?
Die große Firewall filtert vor allem bestimmte Internetinhalte aus, die unerwünscht sind.
Okay, das ist aber schon eine relativ clevere Einrichtung, also man kann eigentlich alles machen, nur sozusagen, wenn es ans Eingemachte geht, da schreiten sie dann ein, aber es ist nicht so, dass es eine Einschränkung im täglichen Bedarf ist, das Ausblenden.
Ein Software-Entwickler, der zum Beispiel...
Eine runde Mate auf mich. Eine runde Mate gibt heute von Elektra aus, weil ihr ein technisches Gerät ein Geräusch im Radio gemacht habt. Unglaublich.
Ich hab die Lautstärke auf dem Radio gesehen.
Okay, also im täglichen Bedarf hat man da eine Einschränkung oder nicht?
Ja, hat man. Gravierend. Man kann die ganzen schönen Filmchen auf YouTube nicht sehen. Kann man nicht. Unter alle anderen Filmchen von Vimeo und so weiter kann man auch nicht sehen. Man kann zum Beispiel nur bestimmte Dienste von Google nutzen. Also alles, was irgendwie interaktiv ist, alles, was Web 2.0 ist, wo man einfach Probleme ist, was publizieren kann. WordPress zum Beispiel, der Begriff WordPress wird gefiltert. Also jeglicher Blog, der WordPress beinhaltet, in der URL, der funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wir lieben China. Die wäre wahrscheinlich die bessere URL für einen Blog, was man von da betreiben kann.
Ja und wenn man die WordPress Installationen macht, sollte man eben den WordPress-Order umbenennen und keinen Link haben, der das Wort WordPress enthält, dann geht es wahrscheinlich auch.
Manchmal kann es so einfach sein. Heute kreativer Umgang mit Technik, um Internet und Kommunikation zu ermöglichen. Wetterfrau, schreibt uns noch ein Beispiel aus Kosovo.
In den 90ern war der Balkan ja auch ein Resengebiet geteilt und da hat man unter anderem die Tete Phonleitungen zwischen den beiden Landesteilen gehabt. Die konnten einander nicht anrufen, Familien waren sozusagen getrennt, konnten nicht spontan sozusagen oder auch wissen, wie es einander geht, aber weiterhin ins Ausland telefonieren. Und zu der Zeit war das jetzt vor diesen ganzen Internetmodems, wie wir sie eigentlich kennen, sondern noch so diese Mailbox-Zeit und es gab da auch schon in der Tat einzelne Computer, die an so Mailbox-Netzwerken teilnehmen konnten. Die konnten, wie gesagt, nicht im Landesinneren zwischen den beiden Hälften kommunizieren, aber wiederum in der eigenen Hälfte und ins Ausland. Und dann wurde in Berlin im Bielefeld von einigen Aktivisten ein Mailbox, wie das im klassischen 80er-Sinde war, betrieben, wo eben die Nachrichten ausgetauscht werden konnten. Eine Mailbox, das war... Das Rauschen und Fiepen, was wir am Anfang der Sendung hatten, dass ja sozusagen diese Einwahl eines Modems und eben durch Rauschen und Fiepen auf eine Telefonader werden da einfach Daten übertragen, dadurch dass das mal eben länger oder kürzer fiept oder höher oder tiefer in der Frequenz. Und so wurden halt hauptsächlich Texte und ja direkte Mitteilungen übertragen und wohl auch innerhalb des Landes weiterverteilt ausgedruckt und dann in andere Städte gebracht sozusagen in ein alternatives Nachrichtensystem, basierend auf Telefon, Ausdrucken und zwischen die beiden Landeselfen.
Ja, man hat da eine Mailbox, da schickt man irgendwelche Informationen hin und diese Mailbox tauscht sich dann irgendwann mit einer anderen Mailbox aus und so vernetzen sich sich alle miteinander und updaten sich gegenseitig. Also es ist dezentral und deswegen auch nicht so leicht anzugreifen.
Und sehr großartig ist es, wir genau solche Technologie gerade verwenden möchten, um für Gebiete, wo das Netz abgeschaltet wird, Backup-Infrastruktur zu bauen mit neueren Protokollen, mit dieser alten Technologie des Synchronisieren. Also wir sind gerade dabei, das irgendwie in einen Topf zu werfen, kräftig umzurühren, wieder auszuschütten und ja, also ohne diese Mailbox-Erfahrung aus den 80ern, könnten wir diese Technologie jetzt gerade nicht bauen, die hoffentlich demnächst fertig ist.
Wir haben im Vorfeld drüber gesprochen, dass das low-leveligste, also das niedrigstechnischste, was wir gefunden haben, war irgendwie USB-Sticks werden umhergetragen, um Internet zu simulieren. Kann man kurz erklären, wie das geht?
Genau, also erstens gab es in Afrika auch mal so einen kleinen Test zwischen zwei Ländern, Datentransfer zu machen. Was ist schneller, die klassische Internetversorgung dort oder eine Brieftaube mit einem USB-Stick? Die Brieftaube hatte natürlich einen wesentlich höheren Datendurchsatz. Das würde vielleicht in manchen Regionen hier in Deutschland auch noch mal der Fall sein. Und ferner gibt es sozusagen auch Regionen, wo Internet gar nicht leicht erschlossen werden kann. Da gibt es keine Telefonleitungen, da ist vielleicht auch bei Funk schwierig oder man hat einfach schlichtweg nicht das Geld. Dort kann man natürlich von Computer zu Computerdaten austauschen. Ganz, ganz früher, bevor es das Internet gab, hat man ja Magnetbänder irgendwie zwischen Computern ausgetauscht und mal eine Kopie irgendwie auf die andere Seite des Atlantiks geschickt. Heute kann das ja schon ein USB-Stick sein. Und da gibt es dann wirklich einen kleinen Schul-Server in der Region Afrikas, wo Leute ihre Mails haben, wo Leute vielleicht auch Terminal-Computer haben, dort ihre Mails empfangen und schreiben, aber sie haben keinen Internetanschluss. Sie haben keine Internetleitung. Sie haben quasi eine Art Briefträger oder mehrere, die mit einem USB-Stick vorbeikommen und den sozusagen an einem Ende von der Einverbindung zum anderen Ende, wo es eben Internet gibt, hin und her tragen und damit nehmen sie sozusagen neue Mails mit, die reinkommen, Antworten, die formuliert wurden, wieder mit in die andere Richtung und dann werden sie, wenn er den USB-Stick das nächste Mal an der Universität anschließt, die Internet hat, verschickt.
Und selbst das planen wir in unserer Backup-Strategie ein, dass mit USB-Sticks die Rechner gesendet werden.
Ich habe dazu eine Nachfrage. Also ich kann mir natürlich jetzt so vorstellen, klar, ich nehme jetzt irgendwie von zu Hause den USB-Stick mit, gehe zu einem anderen Rechner und stecke ihn rein und kopiere die Wortdokumente darunter und dann könnt ihr das da lesen. Oder gibt es tatsächlich ein Protokoll?
Also ich stecke den USB-Stick rein, dann das Software zieht sich das runter und verteilt das quasi, als ob man aus dem Netz kommen würde, beziehungsweise ein, zwei Lösungen davon zusammengeschweißt, die das dann ermöglichen.
Elektra, du wolltest noch?
Es gibt noch eine Steigerung davon. Es gibt Busse, die durch Gegenden fahren, wo relativ schlechte Anbindung ist oder gar keine Anbindung existiert und die haben dann WLAN-Gerät an Bord und immer wenn die irgendwo halten, wo sie regelmäßig vorbeikommen, um Passagiere aufzunehmen, wird lokal drahtlos werden Daten übertragen, also der Bus kommt vorbei, dann wird der lokale Ordner synchronisiert, es werden Daten hin und her gereicht, der Bus fährt weiter und die Daten werden transportiert.
Das digitale Briefträger.
Mir fällt gerade noch ein Fun-Fact ein, diese Berechnung von wegen Brieftaube oder Internet. In Kanada hat das mal jemand gemacht, weil da die Internetgebühren wohl relativ groß sind und hat er ausgerechnet, dass es, wenn er einen Film haben will, den er sich online ausleitet, ist es wohl billiger, eine SSD-Festplatte zu kaufen, den Film mal draufspielen zu lassen, dann zu ihm schicken zu lassen, als es tatsächlich übers Netz runterzuleiten, weil die Datentarife dann wirklich so extrem ist.
Das ist um die neuen Datentarife. Also in Kanada oder generell Nordamerika denkt man generell drüber nach, die Datenträfe deutlich zu erhöhen. In Kanada hat jetzt der erste Prider damit angefangen und da ist es wirklich billiger, eine 750 Gigabyte SSD-Platte zu kaufen und den Film darauf zu kopieren und sich per Post zuschicken zu lassen. Per Express, glaube ich sogar. Per Express, als das übers Netz zu machen.
Es gibt ein klassisches Beispiel aus der Computerliteratur. Man sollte die Datenübertragungsrate eines LKWs, der mit Festplatten beladen ist, nicht unterschätzen.
Kannst du Internet?
archive.org, die Webseite kennt ihr sicher nicht alle. Die haben früher mal das gesamte Internet archiviert. Als ich diese Seite kennengelernt habe, das war so um das Jahr 2000, 2001, war ihr gesamter Datenbestand 4 Terabyte. Damals haben sie wirklich alles, was es im Internet öffentlich erreichbar gab, also auch Treiberdownloads.
Das steht seit neuestem bei mir unterm Schreibtisch als Backup.
Ich war neu schockiert, ich habe nicht meine alte Webseite wiedergefunden.
Alte Vergehen. Wir waren gerade dabei stehen geblieben, in Gebiete, die kein Netz haben, das zu bringen. Notwendigerweise oder in der Not auch damit, dass wir USB-Sticks hin und her fahren. Herr Oberach hat davon gesprochen, dass ihr jetzt ein Paket zusammenbastelt. Wie genau soll das aussehen? Oder an so einem Standard arbeitet, um solche Gebiete wieder zu versorgen?
Genau, ein Survival-Kit. Wie das genau aussieht, kann ich noch gar nicht wirklich sagen, weil wir gerade in der Konzeptionierungsphase erst sind, die aber schon sehr weit vorgeschritten ist. Im Endeffekt geht es dabei um Synchronisieren über sowohl Modemverbindungen, als auch USB-Sticks, als auch über WLAN-Verhandlungen, WLAN-Meshnetzen, die sich dann selbst organisieren. Das Ganze so idiotensicher, dass es jeder benutzen kann, weil oft schallt die Technologie daran, dass Menschen es nicht benutzen können. Wir sind noch nicht fertig damit. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange wir brauchen. Ich hoffe, wir brauchen nicht allzu lange, dass wir es recht bald einsetzen können, dass wir alternative Netzstrukturen aufbauen können, also das alles dezentralisieren können, dass wir eigene Netze betreiben können, dass wir zur Not einfach einen USB-Stick von A nach B tragen und somit Daten in großen Mengen weitergeben können. Ja, das ist der Plan. Da haben wir auch als Protokoll uns das gute alte News-Protokoll ausgesucht.
Das ist also auch irgendwie, was eigentlich nicht mehr benutzt wird, oder?
Es wird noch von ein paar Leuten benutzt. Auch da ist der Plan, es so zu bauen, dass US-Basic-Reinschieben in den Rechnerbooten funktioniert. Und dass er auch alles vorkonfiguriert ist mit einem schicken Webfront. Und dass es halt für den Menschen auch so wie bei Facebook benutzen würde. Was im Hintergrund passiert, ist ihm scheißegal. Und so muss es auch sein.
Ich bin nach wie vor der Ansicht, dass ihr beide euch mal zusammensetzen würdet. Ich glaube, da könnte irgendwas bei rauskommen. Wir sind aber übrigens vor einer guten Stunde, haben wir gesagt, wir wollen noch klären, wie die Leute in Ägypten, das ist ja das Projekt, also Telecomix, wo Herr Urbach von herkommt, die Qualle, also eine Organisation, die sich als Qualle beschreibt, die haben ja gemacht, dass die Leute in Ägypten, die kein Internet mehr haben, einfach wo anrufen konnten und dann sozusagen sich eingewählt haben in das Internet. Das Problem ist, die haben gar kein Internet. Die müssen ja irgendwie die Rufennummer bekommen, wo sie anrufen können, um sich das Internet anzuwählen. Wie habt ihr das hingekriegt? Habt ihr so, wie es damals gemacht wurde, so Flugzeuge, die so Zettel abwerfen, so rufen mich an?
Die waren zu teuer. Wir haben Faxe geschickt.
Nicht dein Ernst?
Doch, wir haben Faxe geschickt. Wohin? An wen? An Universitäten, also gerade die Informatik-Virultäten, Bibliotheken, Krankenhäuser, Internetcafés.
Okay.
Also wir haben sie dahin geschickt, wo wir der Meinung waren, dass die Leute mit was anfangen können.
Wie habt ihr die Nummern rausgekriegt?
Google-Cache. Weil die Seiten waren ja nicht mehr erreichbar in Ägypten. Und wir hatten die Nummer nicht gehabt, also mussten wir auf den Google-Cache zurückkeilen. Wir haben auf der ganzen Welt angefaxed. Und ich habe da eine recht hohe Fax-Rechnung produziert. Und das hat funktioniert. Also wir haben durch ein großes, massives Fax-Aufkommen, haben wir die Nummern gestreut und sie wurden angerufen. Und natürlich dann auch noch im nächsten Schritt, ein Reporter von Al-Jazeera gefragt, die haben wir bei Ägypten nicht erreicht, für Libyen haben wir sie erreicht. Heißt? Dass die, den Menschen, die sie vor Ort treffen, die Nummer einfach in die Hand drücken.
Okay, sie haben aber nicht irgendwie, sondern Laufschrift im Fernsehen eingeblendet.
Nee, aber dafür im Live-Blog. Also sie haben es auch weiterverbreitet, unser Telecomix-Fax. Ja, das ist das Mittel der Wahl gewesen. Wir faxen es halt mal hin.
Es ist ja so, dass du erzählt hast, sie hätte 600 Leitungen, aber ein Großteil davon waren einzelne Rufnummern, wo mehrere Leute anrufen könnten. Das heißt, es gibt einen Blog von Rufnummern, die man anrufen kann, um ins Internet zu kommen. Haben die Mächtigen nicht dann wiederum die Möglichkeit, diese Rufnummern zu sperren?
Die hätten sie, ja. Das Risiko bestand. In Ägypten ist das nicht passiert. In Libyen ist das jetzt passiert. Unsere Einrufnummer in Düsseldorf ist teilweise nicht erreichbar. Sie ist nicht von überall aus erreichbar. Teilweise ist sie blockiert.
Wie schnell könnt ihr da neue Nummern in Beschlag nehmen?
Nicht so schnell. Also einzelne Nummern ja, ganze modernen Bänke dahinter nein, das geht nicht so schnell. Wir haben momentan zum Glück noch das FDN laufen, das ist auch noch nicht blockiert. Und wir haben als Backup noch ein weiteres Projekt hier in Deutschland sitzen, das auf Zuruf innerhalb von 12 Stunden 30 Leitungen bekommt.
Okay, aber das ist nicht eine ernsthafte Gefahr.
Diese Gefahr besteht ja.
Das heißt, ihr müsst dann auch immer gucken, dass die Nummern nicht zu weit verbreitet werden, nicht zu weit bekannt.
Sobald es öffentlich ist, sobald wir es verbreiten, ist es da und kann gesperrt werden. Das Risiko besteht immer, da kommen wir auch nicht ran rum.
Also wenn jemand Nummernblöcke spenden kann?
Also wenn jemand Leitungen hat, so unglaublich viele davon, die auf einer Nummer zusammenlaufen, dann...
Eingelt Folgendes! Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 So, es geht also darüber, die Kontrolle zu behalten, um Kommunikation auf euch zu halten. Wir hören jetzt einen Song, der passend zum Thema ist. Er heißt das von Professor Click und er heißt All Control. Und wir reden gleich noch eine halbe Stunde weiter darüber, wie wir uns ein Paket zusammenschnüren, damit wir hier, falls unsere Regierung beschließt, Alter, wir machen das Internet aus, dass wir so ein Notfallpaket haben. Das wird, ich vermute, nach dem, was ich bis heute im Chaosradio gehört habe, vor allem aus alter Technik bestehen. Aber wir werden gleich mal gucken, wie das so aussehen kann. Bevor wir das klären, machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und wie gesagt vorher noch Professor Click, All Control im Hard Remix.
Ja, für alle, die jetzt denken, ey, da ist ja gar nix.
Richtig, ohne Rundfunkgebühren wär hier auch gar nix.
Pritz.
Powered bei eurer Rundfunkgebühr. Mit?
Ach so, mit drei ist natürlich, oh Gott, ganz vergessen, der Typ ohne Computer ist wieder im Studio und macht Nachrichten.
Ja, den Film brauche ich doch, wenn du das sagst. Bahnreisende müssen morgen Vormittag erneut mit Behinderungen rechnen. Wie die Lokführer-Gewerkschaft GDL mitteilte, soll es für 8.30 Uhr bis 11.30 Uhr Warnstreiks geben. Bestreikt werden die Deutsche Bahn und sechs Privatbahnen. Die Berliner S-Bahn soll diesmal aber nicht bestreikt werden. Schon am Dienstagmorgen hatten Warnstreik den Schienenverkehr für zwei Stunden weitestgehend lahmgelegt. Die GDL will einheitliche Tarifbedingungen für die rund 26.000 Lokführer in Deutschland durchsetzen. In Libyen gehen regierungsteuer Truppen offenbar weiter brutal gegen Aufständische und Protestierende vor. Es wird von zahlreichen Toten berichtet. Regierungen in aller Welt arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran, ihre Staatsbürger aus dem Land zu holen. Die deutsche Marine schickte drei Schiffe. Angesichts der Gewalt in Libyen wächst der internationale Druck auf das Regime. Die Europäische Union beantragte beim UNO-Menschenrechtsrat den Ausschluss des nordafrikanischen Landes. Darüber soll morgen in Genf beraten werden. Nach der Aberkennung des Doktortitels prüft die Universität bei Reuth, ob Verteidigungsminister zu Guttenberg die Hochschule bewusst getäuscht hat. Eine Kommission soll das Verhalten des Ministers untersuchen und bewerten. Der Ältestenrat des Bundestags will erst Mitte März entscheiden, ob die Doktorarbeit auch vom Parlament überprüft wird. SPD und Grüne werfen Union und FDP vor, sie wollten eine rasche Aufklärung verhindern. Nordrhein-Westfalen schafft zum nächsten Wintersemester die Studiengebühren ab. Das hat der Landtag mit den Stimmen der Regierungsparteien SPD und Grüne und der oppositionellen Linken entschieden. Bislang hatten die Hochschulen von ihren Studenten pro Semester 500 Euro kassiert. Mit der Abschaffung der Studiengebühren hat NRW-Ministerpräsidentin Kraft eines ihrer großen Wahlversprechen eingelöst. In der Fußball-Europa-League steht Leverkusen im Viertelfinale. Der VfB Stuttgart ist dagegen ausgeschieden. Die Stuttgarter an der Lage im eigenen Stadion Benfica Lissamon mit 0 zu 2. Das Schinnspiel hatten die Schwaben bereits mit 1 zu 2 verloren. Leverkusen setzte sich beim ukrainischen Club Rakov mit 2 zu 0 durch. Schon die erste Partie hatten die Leverkusen damit 4 zu 0 deutlich für sich entscheiden können. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg währte zwischen minus 5 und minus 8 Grad. Die Nacht ist wenig bewirkt und meist auch sternenklar. Und es ist ziemlich kalt draußen wieder mal. Die T-Satte liegen heute bei minus 13 Grad. Tagsüber wechseln sich dann Sonne und Wolken ab, es bleibt trocken. Die Höchstsatte liegen dann am Freitag zwischen minus 4 und einem Grad plus. Eine Meldung nur aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. Der betrifft immer noch den Stadtring 100 Richtung Wedding zwischen dem Spandauer Damm und dem Dreieck Charlottenburg. Dort staute sich aktuell immer noch bei drei Kilometern.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Barein, zum 15. Februar verringerte sich das Datenvolumen des Landes um 10 bis 20 Prozent. Wahrscheinlich soll so die Protestbewegung zensiert werden, nachdem es zu blutigen Auseinandersetzungen mit die Militär gekommen war. Wie lange die Störung dauern wird, ist noch unklar. Zum Schluss noch eine Entwarnung für Ägypten. Hier fließt der Datenverkehr seit Ende des letzten Monats wieder flüssig.
Wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit man.
Die zwei Sprechstunden. Chaos Radio, eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch. Heute mit Markus Trichter, das ist meine Gestalt. Und zu Gast im Studio sind heute Herr Urbach, der gerade so eben wieder ins Mikrofon zurückfindet. Na, sind Sie schon da? Sind Sie schon da?
Ja, ich bin da.
Das ist unglaublich. Ich bin der Nerd im Studio. Das ist das reine Chaos.
Ich musste Kaffee holen.
Ja, ich musste kommen. Gott des Willen. Ebenfalls am Start und immer brav dabei Elektra Wagenrad. Hallo und guten Abend. Und gerade noch irgendwo verschollen ist der Wetterfrosch. Der hat wahrscheinlich Angst bekommen, dass jetzt doch noch ein Anrufer anruft. Genau, eine halbe Stunde habt ihr noch Zeit, um Fragen zu stellen. Es geht um Internet in Krisengebieten. Also in Gebieten, wo kein Internet ist oder weniger. Ich hab's gerade in der Datenverkehrsmeldung gehört. In Bahrain wurde das Netz einfach schmaler gemacht. Wir haben heute schon über zahlreiche Projekte gesprochen, wo es darum ging, dass man einfach Netz wieder anstellen bringt oder Kommunikation anstellen bringt, wo keine mehr ist. Jetzt frage ich mich, kann man sowas auch aufheben, Herr Urbach? Also das Netz ist schmaler, kann man so irgendwie wieder mehr Bandbreite dazu geben?
Nicht so ohne Weiteres. Also einfach auch nur durch mehr Uplinks bereitstellen, wie wir es auch jetzt bereits tun. Wenn das Netz gedrosselt wird, dann können wir da nicht viel machen. Das ist dann einfach eine technische Konfiguration der Router.
Okay, also was wir hier machen können mit den Mitteln, die wir heute hier besprechen, die sozusagen überhaupt Kommunikation an den Start bringen, mit der Bandbreite, das müssen wir dann mal später bearbeiten. Gibt es da schon irgendwie so Zukunftsszenarien? Wie kriege ich mehr Bandbreite an Orte, die wenig Bandbreite haben?
Darüber machen wir uns momentan noch wenig Gedanken, denn erstmal jetzt darum überhaupt, da irgendwo reinzuhalten.
Entschuldigung, aber du musst dir doch sozusagen noch über die Hand machen. Du hast doch selber erzählt, dass das sehr wichtig gewesen wäre, gerade in Ägypten.
Ja, aber wir haben einfach momentan nicht die technische, wir haben nicht die Technologie dafür.
Du musst aber jetzt noch erzählen, warum das ist, also warum ihr eigentlich noch mehr Bandbreite hättet brauchen können.
Wir glauben zwar nicht an Logs bei Telecomix, aber gerade wenn wir neue Geräte an den Start bringen, gucken wir schon mal nach, so funktionieren die richtig, wegen Debugging halt einfach, dann lassen wir doch Logs mitlaufen. Und wir hatten einen Zugangsknoten, da rief jemand an.
Also, wie gesagt, auch immer zusammengehört, also in Ägypten kein Internet mehr, die Leute konnten aber außerhalb von Ägypten Telefonnummer anrufen und da wiederum war dann Internet dran und das ist also eine Verbindung, die ist 56K, das ist so ähnlich, GPHS, also das ist ein langsames Mobilfunknetz, was es überhaupt gibt und noch ein bisschen langsamer diese Verbindung. Und dann ist Folgendes passiert.
Und dann schauten wir so in die Logs rein und plötzlich sahen wir, dass der Teilnehmer sich die neueste Folge von How I Met Your Mother heruntergeladen hat und das war irgendwie ja fast schon zum Lachen gewesen. So, hey, ich hab nichts, ich lad mir einen Film runter und eine Serie.
Unglaublich. Und der Anrufer kam von wo?
Der kam aus Ägypten.
Ja, könnt ihr mal sehen, wozu man so ein Netz überall braucht. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit schon drüber geredet, wie man Netz nach Afrika bekommt oder nach Timor oder Ägypten oder Libyen. Und die Frage ist, ein bisschen die kleine Angst, gerade Nerds neigen ein bisschen zur Paranoia, was passiert, wenn jetzt hier in Deutschland das Internet abgeschaltet wird? Wir wollen jetzt noch zum Schluss eine kleine Kiste backen, wo alles drin ist, was wir brauchen, um zu kommunizieren. Also möglicherweise nicht mal mit dem Netz, aber irgendwie mit anderen Leuten und möglichst nicht in echt, sondern übers Gerät.
Also kann man eigentlich ganz grundlegend anfangen bei Funkgeräten.
Funkgeräten?
Ja, da fällt Telefone, aber wenn wir jetzt nicht von Scheinzeitenumgebung ausgehen, dann sollte auf jeden Fall ein, zwei WLAN-Geräte und WLAN-Antennen dabei sein. WLAN-Antennen, da gibt es ja so welche, die rundherum strahlen, oder solche gerichteten Antennen, dass man wirklich eine weitere Verbindung über mehrere Kilometer von einem Punkt zum anderen Punkt überbrücken kann. So Richtfunkantennen für den WLAN-Bereich zwei Stück und entsprechende Geräte, dass man darüber schon mal Netzwerk bekommen kann, wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal praktisch, um sich an den nächsten Nachbarn anzuschließen.
Also ich würde da so eine WAN-DAN-Strategie vorschlagen. Solange das Telefonnetz noch geht, kann man analoge Modems verwenden. Die Möglichkeit besteht dann immer noch.
Wo kriege ich heutzutage noch analoges Modem her?
Gibt es sowas überhaupt noch?
Die SDN-Karten natürlich auch nicht vergessen, oder?
Gibt es immer noch, weil es gibt immer noch Leute, die irgendwo sitzen und nur eine analoge Telefonleitung haben und sonst nichts.
Und mal ganz dumm gesagt, in jedem aktuellen Dell Notebook ist ein Modem drinne. Also die meisten Leute haben ihren Notebooks Modems drinne und vergessen sie vollkommen, weil sie sie halt nicht brauchen. Aber gut, jetzt im Mac ist es nicht drinne, aber so in einem Dell, in einem Acer, überall sind noch Modems eingebaut.
Ein weiterer Grund, sich einen Laptop zu kaufen, kein festen Computer.
Ich denke aber, es wird mittlerweile langsam verschwinden aus den Notebooks, aber ein älteres Gerät, was vielleicht drei, vier Jahre alt ist, dürfte es in aller Regel noch drin haben. Gut, aber das ist die Strategie, die noch funktioniert, wenn es noch ein funktionierendes Telefonnetz gibt. Aber was, wenn es das auch nicht mehr gibt oder nie vorhanden war?
Dann haben wir eine Meshpotato dabei.
Ja, aber die Meshpotato kann nur auf kurze Entfernung kommunizieren. Man braucht dann schon relativ viele Meshpotatos. Um vielleicht eine Stadt zu vernetzen, dass also innerhalb einer Stadt noch Kommunikation stattfindet, dafür geht es noch. Um vorzugreifen, der allerletzte Resort, das ist das allerletzte Mittel, auf das man zurückgreifen kann, ist Kurzwellenfunk. Das ist dann wirklich die allerletzte Methode.
Jetzt irgendwie um Gespräche zu führen oder ist das eigentlich um Datenverkehr zu haben?
Da kann man auch Datenverkehr darüber machen. Und zwar braucht man dafür wirklich nur ein Laptop und eine Soundkarte oder irgendeine Art von Computer und eine Soundkarte. Da gibt es Software. Für Linux gibt es eine Software, die heißt Soundmodem. Und die emuliert dann quasi einen Kurzwellenmodem über die Soundkarte.
Und da brauche ich aber noch eine Gegenstelle. Wie weit kann die dann weg sein?
Das hängt von dem verwendeten Funkgerät und von der Datenrate ab.
Wir wollen ja gerade die Christi für zu Hause sagen. Es muss ja irgendwas sein, was du sagen kannst, nicht so groß wie mein Zimmer, sondern halt haushaltsüblich, sage ich mal.
Haushaltsüblich, heute auch kaum noch, aber gibt es immer noch die CB-Funktechnik, da kann man Reichweiten zwischen 30 und 70 Kilometern erzielen unter guten Bedingungen mit einem einzelnen Gerät.
Genau, wir haben während der Ägypten-Sache mit Hemradio den Funkabgehörten auch gemoßt über Hemradio. Das ist eine Funktechnologie, die irgendwie funktioniert. Für mich ist das Magie. Da gibt es aber auch durchaus Leute, die richtig Ahnung von haben. Bei Hemradio haben wir auch Erfolge mit erzielt, dass wir mit Leuten kommuniziert haben, über Morse in dem Fall. Wir haben auch die Nummern gemoßt gehabt, also so war das möglich.
Ein Morse-Alphabet?
Ja, das ist nicht umsonst erfunden worden, das funktioniert auch immer noch nach wie vor. Ein Leitspruch von Telecomix ist, to provide every means of communications available. Und das Available ist das ganz Wichtige dabei. Wenn nur Funk da ist, nutzen wir Funk.
Was Elektra vorgestellt hat, ist, sie kommunizieren mit Fiepen und Rauschen. Und da gibt es verschiedene Standards, welche Frequenz, welche Zeichen bedeutet. Das ist in diesem Soundmodem, was du vorgestellt hast, auf jeden Fall enthalten in dieser Software, dass du da alle möglichen Standards mit sprechen kannst. Und worüber dann dieses Tonsignal transferiert wird, ob das jetzt vielleicht auch einfach ein Radiosender ist. Also Elektra hat bestimmt schon mehr FM-Radiosender mal gebaut.
Wie, möglicherweise könnten wir hier sozusagen einfach eine Datenverbindung aufbauen?
Natürlich, wir können auch hier über Radio Fizz jetzt live ein paar Bits senden. Und dann können das Leute mit ihren Hemradio Stations oder einfach mit ihren Laptops, einer Soundkarte und einem Mikrofon dran direkt dekodieren.
Wir schicken Stucksett über unsere Welle, geil!
Genau, dann kannst du auch über ein Feldtelefon eine Datentäterverbindung machen.
Kann man einfach als Sounddatei ablegen und dann abspielen, dann können die Leute die Daten entfangen.
Das hört sich ja großartig an. Ganz ehrlich, Hand auf Herz, wie viele davon habt ihr zu Hause rumliegen? Von den Sachen, die wir gerade vorgestellt haben? Okay, Herr Urbach ist raus.
Nee, der Herr Urbach ist drinnen. Herr Funkgeräte. Wir hatten nämlich ganz wenig, der Herr Urbach. Tatsächlich, wieso? Ich bin gerade nach Berlin gezogen und mein Zeug steht noch in Hessen.
Oh mein Gott, wenn jetzt das Netz ausfällt.
Ja, bin ich taub und blind.
Aber Hessen ist versorgt.
Hessen ist versorgt, ja. Also ich habe momentan nur meinen Laptop hier. Das Kaimodem hat gar nichts. Ich wäre ziemlich taub und blind. Wenn ich mein Zeug hier hätte, hätte ich wenigstens Modem, ISDN-Karten und Funk, also WLAN-Verbindungen. Das hätte ich. Ich kann jedem wirklich nur empfehlen, sich dringend irgendwie nochmal Modem zu besorgen. Ich habe am besten auch einen Ex-Handles, wenn der Rechner kaputt geht, dass man einfach einen anderen Rechner ranpacken kann. Die gibt es recht günstig auf diversen Online-Marktplätzen. Wahrscheinlich sind sie nach dieser Sendung teurer dann.
Plötzlich ja auch von in der Modem-Branche, verstehe ich.
eBay für ein paar Euro wird es da bestimmt einige geben.
Und apropos Modems, wir brauchen Modems, ganz viele davon.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Ihr habt ja diese Nummer gebracht, also ihr stellt irgendwo Rechner hin. Ihr habt jetzt einen großen Kooperationspartner. Ihr sammelt jetzt aber nur Modems.
Ihr sammelt jetzt nicht irgendwie Rechner? Ich brauche kein Rechner sammeln, wenn ich keine Modems habe. Also Rechner sind einfacher zu bekommen als Modems heutzutage. Okay, verstehe. Modems wären ganz super. Wenn man im Berliner Raum ist, kann man die Donnerstags in CCC Berlin abgeben. Da werden die dann eingesammelt. Und dann werden die von Telecomix weiterverwertet.
Okay, egal. Wenn welche da sind, dann...
Also ich nehme auch 144er Modems.
Du wolltest gerade sagen, sonst habe ich noch zu Hause liegen, glaube ich.
Da kann ich aushelfen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir tatsächlich noch einen Anrufer. Christian.
Ich habe zwei Fragen im Endeffekt. Beide vielleicht etwas sicherheitskritisch. Und zwar ist es einmal bezüglich dem Problem, dass in Libyen ja die Nummern gesperrt werden und neue Telefonnummern relativ schwer zu beschaffen sind. Ob es da irgendwelche Wege dran vorbei gibt mit, ich sage einfach mal, einem Stapel SIM-Karten, die eine Rufnummerweiterleitung auf den endgültigen Zugangspunkt machen. Ob sowas schon mal irgendwie gecheckt wurde, ob das geht? Und die zweite Sache wäre im Bezug auf die Mesh-Netzwerke, puncto Ortungssicherheit. Man kennt es irgendwie von damals CB-Funk, wenn sie dann irgendwie um einen Block fahren und nach dir suchen.
Also zu den Rufnummern, wir haben den Effekt der Reihe, dass Nummern blockiert sind. Einfach zum Gehen sind die nicht. Über Mobilfunknetze haben wir noch nicht probiert. Einfach auch, weil wenn jemand eine Mobilfunknummer aus dem Ausland anruft, diese Kosten explodieren schlagartig. Und es ist so schon teuer genug für die Leute, die oft nicht wirklich viel Geld haben. Und das wollen wir ihnen auch nicht zumuten. Unter Umständen erkennen sie es nicht, dass sie eine Mobilfunknummer anrufen, die unglaublich teuer wird, wenn sie sie anrufen.
Na, aber wäre das nicht tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit? Ihr könntet euch ja auch irgendwie Voice-over-IP-Nummern...
Voice-over-IP und Modems will nicht wirklich zusammen funktionieren.
Tatsächlich?
Da arbeiten wir noch dran. Da gibt es gerade einen ZIP-Provider in Polen, der gerade was deploit, was das betrifft. Momentan ist das Protokoll nicht auf Modems ausgelegt und will nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Da ist dann die Soundqualität so schlecht? Die Signale?
Zu hohe Verlustrate der Daten. Die Lizenz ist zu hoch.
Für Voice-over-IP wird ein Audiokodec verwendet, der verlustbehaftet ist. Bei der Datenübertragung kommt es darauf an, dass das sehr präzise übertragen wird. Der Codec, der die Datenbandbreite reduziert, damit Voice-over-IP leichter möglich wird, der schneidet genau die Sachen weg. Mit dem Codec G711 dürfte es vielleicht gehen, aber jetzt schweife ich ab und wir kommen zu sehr dicht.
Die Idee besteht schon, dass man eine Nummer-Weiterleitung macht, aber da gibt es noch ein paar Probleme. Zur zweiten Frage, warum sollte man Mesh-Netzwerke orten wollen? Du willst einfach fragen, ob das geht und wie man sich da verschützen kann.
Rein theoretisch, ob das irgendwie angedacht ist, weil im schlimmsten Fall kommunizieren da ja zwei Lager, sage ich mal, irgendwie. Und wenn Papa Staat da hinterher ist, der weiß, was die sich einfallen lassen.
Ja, du hast recht, das ist möglich. Also jede Radioübertragung ist im Prinzip ortbar. Man kann die anpeilen, also bis zu ihrer Reichweite, das ist möglich. Genauso kann man auch die Sendemasten von Radio Fritz ganz einfach aufspüren, wenn man dann mit einer Richtantenne durch die Gegend läuft und die einfach anpeilt. Es gibt aber sogar noch was, also wenn zum Beispiel die Kommunikation wirklich nur auf einzelne Worte oder Sätze beschränkt ist, dann kann man das so langsam und bei so einer niedrigen Senderate machen, dass man das mit dem Empfänger gar nicht mehr empfangen kann. Das geht dann im Rauschteppich unter. Funkamateure verwenden das, um mit unglaublich niedriger Sendeleistung um die Welt rumzufunken. Da gibt es dann so eine Software, die analysiert das Rauschen mit einer Fourier-Transformation. Und man kann auf dem Display quasi diese Mausezeichen sehen. Das lässt sich kaum nachweisen. Also da muss man wirklich genau die Frequenz wissen, auf der das stattfindet. Ist aber wahrscheinlich für die meisten Leute vollkommen unrealistisch, so etwas zu unternehmen.
Also es gibt theoretisch eine theoretische Umgebung, aber sozusagen für das Mesh-Netzwerk ist es nicht praktikal?
Also im Expertenmodus kann man zum Beispiel so eine Information, wie hier wird gerade geschossen, die kann man in den Rauschlevel des Empfängers integrieren. Und dann fällt den Behörden das gar nicht auf, wenn ihnen die Frequenz nicht bekannt ist.
Da muss man ja auch unterscheiden, was man ortet. Ob man jetzt einen Teilnehmer ortet, der einfach am Netzwerk hängt oder einen Teilnehmer orten will, der etwas bestimmtes kommuniziert. Und da gibt es ja auch Mittel und Wege, wie man Leute anonym an solchen Netzen und an der Publikation von Inhalten teil lassen kann. Oder auch eben verschlüsselt, dass man eben gar nicht sieht, was dort genau übertragen wird. Und dann sieht man, okay, da gibt es jemand, der hängt da irgendwie am Netzwerk, hat vielleicht auch Internet, aber ob er jetzt wirklich das veröffentlicht hat, was am anderen herausfällt, ist dann nicht zu rauhrenbar.
Ein Nachtrag noch zu den Mesh-Netzwerken. Die Geräte haben relativ wenig Leistung und die werden dann unter Umständen auch zahlreich und können autonom arbeiten. Man kann es schon sehr schwer machen. Also da müssten dann quasi in dem Moment, wo die Revolution am Gange ist, müssten sie Tage damit zubringen, diese einzelnen Geräte aufzuspüren, die sich dann auch noch schönerweise immer wenn eins ausfällt, wenn sie noch eine Alternative haben, einen neuen Pfad bilden. Das ist schon sehr schwer. Ich glaube kaum, dass es in so einem richtigen Krisenmoment, dass da jemand noch Zeit und Lust hat, dem nachzugehen.
Das ist sozusagen einer der Vorteile, dass es ja aus vielen einzelnen Einheiten besteht. Man müsste das, um das Netz zu zerstören, alle auf einen Schlag wegnehmen.
Da müsste man sehr viele aus dem Verkehr ziehen, gewissermaßen.
Wie hoch ist die Rate in so einer Stadt, wenn die gut verteilt sind?
Du meinst, wie viele Geräte man auch bräuchte. Wenn man keine Redundanz hat, wenn man immer nur eine Verbindung hat, dann kann man das Netz natürlich auch leicht stilllegen. Im Prinzip wird das Netz umso besser, je mehr Geräte daran beteiligt sind. Es gibt mittlerweile sehr viele Geräte, die man dafür hernehmen kann. Es gibt da diese Linux-Distribution OpenWrt. Hier kann man die ganzen Routing-Protokolle installieren. Die haben alle diese Möglichkeit und da kann man mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, einen großen Prozentsatz des Marktes damit ausstatten und damit solche Netze aufbauen.
Christian, Frage beantwortet?
Absolut, ich sage besten Dank und ein super klasse Projekt auf jeden Fall.
Vielen Dank und schönen Abend dir noch. Bis denn, tschüss. Liebe Hörer, wir müssen ernsthaft mal reden. Es ist jetzt 10 vor 12. Diese Sendung geht 2 Stunden, wir haben jetzt noch 10 Minuten. Und jetzt ruft ihr an. Was zur Hölle habt ihr ja an? Jetzt anrufen 0331 77 91 10. Nicht vorher verstanden. Peter. Warum rufst du es jetzt an? Was ist denn hier los?
Ja, ich hab ganz entspannt zugehört.
Ich hab euch immer gesagt, wir dürfen die Sendung nicht so spannend machen. Die Leute rufen nicht an, die müssen sich langweilen. Die müssen sich so langweilen, dass sie hier anrufen.
Okay.
Aber du hast noch eine Frage.
Ja, ich hätte eine Frage an CCC. Und zwar, es ist jetzt irgendwie noch nicht gefallen, oder ich hab es jetzt wirklich verpasst, aber ich glaub nicht. Wie wird jetzt, ihr nennt das ein Mashed-Potato, ne?
Mashed-Potato, das ist ein Gerät, das ist unabhängig von CCC.
Genau, das Gerät für Krisengebiete, was ihr gesagt habt, in diesen Entwicklungsländern vornehmlich. Ja, wie wird das jetzt, kann ich es mit normalen Batterien betreiben? Oder hat das eine Art Akku? Was hat das?
Das Gerät hat einen Anschluss für ein Telefon, das hat einen Anschluss für einen Netzwerkkabel und das hat noch eine DC-Buchse. Und über alle drei Buchsen kannst du da Spannung reinjagen. Zwischen 9 und 40 Volt ist der Bereich, in dem es funktioniert. Das ist ein recht großer Eingangsbereich.
DC heißt diese kleine Strom-Gleichspannungsbuchse, die man eigentlich in jedem technischen Gerät mit dem kleinen schwarzen Rundfleck hat.
Man kann es über das Telefonkabel, übers Netzwerkkabel speisen. Es nimmt Gleichspannung und wenn man aus Versehen mal die Polarität umdreht, dann geht es nicht kaputt. Wenn man zu hohe Gleichspannung reichen macht, dann geht eine Schutzschaltung an und da bricht es einfach. Es ist dafür gemacht, dass Leute, die technisch nicht versiert sind, die Dinge in die Hand nehmen und irgendwas damit tun und sie gehen nicht kaputt.
Okay, und im Krisenfall, wenn wir keinen Strom haben, wenn die Leute dort keinen Strom haben?
Angenommen, du bist in einem Katastrophengebiet, wo nach einer Explosion im Vulkanausbruch irgendwelche schrottigen Autos rumstehen, nimmst du dir einfach eine alte Autobatterie oder eine Lastwagenbatterie. Mit einer Lastwagenbatterie wird das Gerät mehrere Wochen arbeiten.
Okay, ja und Batterien gehen aber gar nicht oder gehen nicht?
Doch, natürlich das geht auch. Also du bräuchtest dann halt irgendwie ein Batteriefach, wo du mehrere Batterien einlegen kannst. Wie gesagt, die Mindestspannung ist 9 Volt. Um zu telefonieren, wenn es nur funken soll, dann tun es auch 3, 3 Volt.
Wie groß muss die Solarzelle sein?
Ja, Solarzelle. Das hängt vom Gebiet ab. Also in Südafrika kommt man mit einem 10 Watt Solarpanel hin. Das ist wie groß? 10 Watt Solarpanel, das ist ungefähr 20 x 30 cm groß.
Und ein A4-Blatt?
Das kriegt man über Ebay für 40 Euro. Aber in unseren Breiten, zum Beispiel im Winter, jetzt haben wir gerade den düstesten Monat, oder im Januar muss man schon ein sehr großes Solarpanel haben, um da überhaupt noch ausreichend Energie ernten zu können, weil die Sonneneinstrahlung einfach zu gering ist.
Gibt es irgendwie so noch Taschendynamos oder was auch immer?
Selbstverständlich.
Kann man alles machen?
Kann man alles machen. Also irgendwas mit einer Kobel dran. Windkraft bietet sich in dem Fall an. Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten. In der zivilisierten Welt, nach so einer Katastrophe, steht genügend Gerät rum, was man einfach hernehmen kann. Autobatterien, Lkw-Batterien haben 12 Volt. Auch eine Batterie vor einer Alarmanlage geht. Oder Monozellen aus der Taschenlampe.
Man kann jeden Motor auch als Generator benutzen, einfach dran drehen, dann kommt da wieder Strom raus.
Eine ganz kurze Frage noch. Wie heißt denn bitte die URL, wo das Internet gesaved wird?
Oder was ihr vorhin gesagt habt? Das Internetarchiv, das kanntest du noch nicht. Unglaublich.
Kein Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit an dieser Stelle?
Früher war es mal sehr vollständig. Das heißt archive.org, also archive mit v.org.
Mittlerweile beschränken sich darauf, bestimmte Webseiten mehr oder weniger semi-regelmäßig aufzunehmen. Ich habe mal in meinem Blog geguckt, da war es dann so, ich glaube im Halbjahresrhythmus haben sie einen Snapshot in diese Datenbank reingeladen. Aber vollständig ist es in der Tat nicht mehr. Aber doch sehr interessant.
Ich habe das früher benutzt, um esoterische Treiber von irgendwelchen Windows-Geräten runterzuladen, wo die Firma schon lange nicht mehr existiert hat, weil sie die HTTP-Downloads einfach archiviert haben. Davon haben sie mittlerweile Raumsabstand genommen. Das passt einfach nicht mehr in 4 Terabyte.
Das ist richtig.
Dann hoffe ich, dass das Gerät für uns zu kaufen ist. Oder ist es jetzt schon zu kaufen für uns?
Das ist zu kaufen. Das wird vertrieben unter anderem von der Firma Atcom in China, in Shenzhen. Da kann man das bestellen. Oder in Südafrika.
Kennt ihr Bang, die Firma aus China? Geschrieben.
Sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Die hat ganz viele Sachen gemacht für Konsolen. Ganz speziell, wo man rumslagen konnte. Ganz coole Sachen, die es sonst nirgendwo gab. Auf jeden Fall, es gilt auch nicht, Leute.
Auf jeden Fall, das Gerät kann man direkt beim Hersteller kaufen.
Ja, das ist super. Und ja, dann viel Erfolg damit. Und ich würde echt cool finden, wenn ich meinen alten Game Boy nehmen könnte, die Batterie nehmen könnte und es damit betreiben könnte. Ich habe heute auch Batterien gekauft, die sind haltbar bis 2018, 2017 oder so.
Na alles klar, einfach den passenden Adapter noch dazu anschaffen und dann geht das klar. Super, alles klar. Bis dann, tschüss. So, na schön, zum Schluss doch noch ein paar Anrufe, meine Güte. So, wir sind jetzt fast schon wieder am Ende.
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall noch hinweisen.
Wait, ich muss ehrlich sagen, bevor wir, also nachdem wir jetzt auch noch auf Dinge hingewiesen haben und noch eine Musik gespielt haben, dann kommt Henrik Schröder mit dem neuen Fall, denn das Chaosradio ist jetzt gleich zu Ende. Aber Wetterforscht hat noch einen Hinweis? Oder zwei oder drei?
Eigentlich nur einen kurzen, und zwar wo man unter anderem auch Elektra häufiger findet und wer sich auch mit diesem ganzen, ja, wie macht man ein WLAN-Netzwerk autonomerweise beschäftigt, sind die Freifunker, die hatten auch im Oktober letzten Jahres 2010 eine Sendung hier im Chaosradio gemacht. Die treffen sich jeden Mittwoch in der Berliner Sea-Base, eine abgestürzene Raumstation an der Jernobitsbrücke. Immer so am späteren Abend, so ab 9 Uhr, geht es dann da rund.
Einfach mal nach Sea-Base googeln, dann findet man das.
Genau. Und da, wer sich für diese Sachen interessiert, findet da auf jeden Fall Anschluss. Und ansonsten werden wir die Wiki-Seite zu dieser Sendung noch bestimmt etwas pflegen und ein paar Links.
Bestimmt macht das noch irgendjemand, glaube ich.
Es ist ein Wiki.
Es ist ein Wiki. Es kann ja jeder arbeiten. Deswegen machen es auch alle. Das ist genauso wie putzen in der Wiki.
Alle, die heute nicht angerufen haben, müssen das Wiki pflegen.
Werter Frosch, Elektra Wagenrad und Herr Urbach, vielen Dank für dieses Chaosradio. Wir wissen jetzt, wie wir beim Krisenfall an Internet kommen oder zumindest untereinander kommunizieren können. Diese ganze Sendung gibt es natürlich auch als Podcast unter chaosradio.de. Die wird sie wahrscheinlich auftauchen. Auch auf fritz.de wird das natürlich geben. Ich empfehle mich an dieser Stelle und mir bleibt natürlich nur noch eins zu sagen, was wirklich wichtig ist und was ihr beherzigen solltet. Ich glaube, ich habe es schon ein paarmal gesagt, man kann sich oft genug sagen, macht immer schön eure Back-ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.